nun ich würde auf keinen Fall für macron
Stimmen
aurelation wie ist denn jetzt die Lage
im Vergleich zu den letzten
Präsidentschaftswahlen vor fünf Jahren
ja im Hinblick auf die letzten Wahlen
von danach fragen Sie vor fünf Jahren ja
katastrophal
[Musik]
katastrophal warum wegen der rechten
nein wegen der Leute die wir damals
gewählt haben die sind einfach nicht auf
der Höhe
in ihrer Blase und sind einfach gar
nicht bei den Franzosen und bei dem was
die Franzosen brauchen
im Zentrum der Frage steht natürlich
immer auch die Kaufkraft ist das ja ja
klar genau deswegen genau deswegen das
ist das Thema man muss diese Kaufkraft
den Franzosen zurückgeben denn wir
verlieren hier alles was wir in den
vergangenen fünf Jahren uns erarbeitet
haben wie läuft das in Deutschland
in Deutschland läuft ganz gut ja gut sie
sind begabter als wir Resultate
wie würden sich denn die Ergebnisse
auswirken wenn jetzt beispielsweise
Marine Le Pen gewählt für die würde sich
das in Europa Auswirkungen naja also da
da muss ich Ihnen gestehen dass ich mir
diese Frage noch nicht vorgelegt habe
denn ich werde nicht für Marine stimmen
sie kaufen gerade ein und da ist die
Kaufkraft ein Problem in Frankreich
die Politiker sagen immer nein aber ich
glaube schon insbesondere in einer Stadt
wie Paris
aber wenn marien gewählt wird was hätte
das für Folgen für Europa und Frankreich
für mich wäre das dramatisch
die Folge wäre ja dass die Franzosen
sich wieder auf sich selbst zurückziehen
würden
Europa hätte dann solche Sachen
kaum noch eine Existenzberechtigung denn
Marie Le Pen hat ja gar nichts
konsequentes in ihrem Wahlprogramm
würden weiß überhaupt nicht mit wem sie
zusammen regieren will was sie mit dem
Programm überhaupt will sie sagt immer
gut wir schließen die Grenzen wir
konzentrieren uns wieder auf uns selbst
und nur auf die echten Franzosen ich
sehe da kein Programm kein Wahlprogramm
dahinter
was ist denn das Problem des Herrn
ich glaube
sehr schwierigen Zeit regieren müssen da
waren die Attentate dann war die kovic
Pandemie und schließlich der
ukraine-krieg der vielleicht dafür
gesorgt hat dass er die Reformen die er
wollte nicht durchführen konnte und dann
ist da auch eine gewisse Arroganz eine
mangelnde Bürger Nähe die man ihm
vorwirft vielleicht ist das ein Problem
und die Beziehungen zwischen Deutschland
und Frankreich ist das wichtig für sie
oh ja das ist ganz ganz wichtig denn das
sind die beiden Mächte die sozusagen der
den Sockel darstellen für die
Europäische Union
ich danke Ihnen
und bei mir ist jetzt ein Spezialist und
Experte für die deutsch-französischen
Beziehungen auch für diese Situation in
Frankreich dieses Jahr hat sich begrüße
dr Julian torell sie sind von der
Universität sie parisen und beschäftigen
sich mit dem Verhältnis Deutschland
Frankreichs sehr intensiv wir haben
jetzt gerade heute morgen ein paar
Passanten hier unten gefragt amor macht
was ist das Thema für Sie und da kommt
heraus dass man vor allem bei macron
sagt naja der residiert da in Paris da
hat er mit folgt nichts zu tun wie kommt
es zu dieser Einschätzung
ja also macron kommt ursprünglich aus
dem Norden Frankreichs aus einem Jahr
100 Kilometer von Paris ungefähr
und ist jemand der mir schon mit 17 nach
Paris gekommen sind und natürlich
seitdem in dieser Pariser Blase lebt und
er ist im Moment in Frankreich
wird wahrgenommen als als manchmal ein
bisschen arrogant manchmal ein bisschen
überheblich und dieser Eindruck hat sich
bestätigt im Laufe der letzten Wochen
weil macron sich geweigert hat mit den
11 weiteren Kandidaten zu debattieren
über die Probleme Frankreichs und die
über die Lösungen die er vorschlagen
will und
er wollte sie einfach nicht als
Staatspräsident mit seinen
Herausforderungen konfrontieren und das
hat einfach diesen Eindruck der
Überheblichkeit bestätigt
die Themen wir haben ein Thema diese
Puffer dashar also die Kaufkraft gehört
auch von den Passanten immer wieder das
ist eher ein großes Thema das kann man
in Deutschland nicht so ganz
nachvollziehen was ist der Kern dieses
Problem sind in Frankreich also
eigentlich ist das Thema Kaufkraft gar
kein Thema das
Wirtschaftsforschungsinstitut of ce das
auch in Paris angesiedelt ist hat sich
mit dem Thema beschäftigt und hat
bewiesen dass im Laufe der letzten fünf
Jahre bzw seit macrons Wahl sich die
Kaufkraft der Franzosen um jährlich
0,9% erhöht hat das heißt über fünf
Jahre um 300 Euro netto im Grunde
genommen ist das kein Thema oder aber
trotzdem hat sich das Thema durchgesetzt
insbesondere angesichts der Diskussion
um die Spritpreise seit dem letzten
Herbst und das Thema hat sich quasi
ununterbrochen seitdem durchgesetzt im
Wahlkampf selbstverständlich vor dem
Hintergrund der ukraine-krise ist das
Thema noch Landtag geworden und die
Angst der Franzosen hat sich dadurch
auch zugespitzt welche Rolle spielt bei
der Wahl die Innenpolitik bzw die
Außenpolitik denn wir erleben ja macron
als einen der in der internationalen
Politik immer wieder auftritt ist
derjenige der am meisten mit Wladimir
Putin telefoniert hat auch bei ihm war
um diesen Krieg zu beenden oder
zumindest Gespräche anzuregen ja und das
wird ihm eigentlich vorgeworfen obwohl
er dadurch dass er den Kontakt pflegt
zum russischen Staatspräsidenten auch in
seiner Rolle als Präsident oder
Vorsitzender der des EU-Ratsvorsitzes
mit mit Wladimir Putin spricht es wird
ihm vorgeworfen nicht von allen und
nicht mal von manchen Herausforderern
die es für klug halten
das vermittelt selbstverständlich den
Eindruck dass macron sich eher auf der
internationalen Bühne betätigt hat in
den letzten Monaten und vielleicht auch
in den letzten Jahren aber die Franzosen
reagieren jetzt auf die letzten
Ereignisse oder die also die Ereignisse
der letzten Zeit und das ist tatsächlich
es ist tatsächlich so dass macron sehr
spät in den Wahlkampf offiziell
reingekommen ist er hat seine Kandidatur
um um die Wiederwahl sehr spät erklärt
sowieterin oder oder generaldogol in den
60er Jahren auch und das besteht die
noch einmal diesen Eindruck dass er sich
eher um EU oder Außenpolitik beschäftigt
beschäftigt also sich damit beschäftigt
als um Innenpolitik obwohl ich überhaupt
nicht der Fall ist der war doch das muss
man auch betonen permanent in Frankreich
unterwegs und hat sich mit seinen
Wählern aber auch nicht mit denjenigen
die nicht für ihn gewählt haben vor fünf
Jahren sehr intensiv auseinandergesetzt
der teuer wir sprechen gleich weiter wir
wollen einmal ein bisschen Rückblick
möglich machen auf einen fulminanten
Sieg den wir vor fünf Jahren von
Emmanuel macron erlebt haben und die
Bilder die sicherlich dafür sprechen
der Moment des Triumphs Emmanuel macron
ist mit 39 Jahren der neue Präsident
Frankreichs und schreitet zunächst zur
Europahymne erst danach zur Marseilles
vor dem Museum Louvre seinen Sieg ab
unter den Augen der Millionen Franzosen
verspricht er europäische Einheit den
Abbau sozialer Spannungen im Land und
Reformen die Frankreich stärken sollen
den Franzosen soll es besser gehen die
Euphorie dieses Abends wehrt nur
anderthalb Jahre die rechtsextreme
Marine muss nicht lange auf die
Unzufriedenheit im Land warten um daraus
Kapital zu schlagen
vielen Dank meine Freunde
ich möchte auch ein Wort richten an
diejenigen die heute für Madame Leben
gestimmt haben nein nein nein but sie
nicht aus pfeift sie nicht aus sie haben
sie haben heute zum Ausdruck gebracht
dass sie zornig sind dass sie
verzweifelt sind
manchmal auch haben sie Überzeugungen
zum Ausdruck gebracht aber ich
respektiere diese Menschen ich werde
aber alles tun während der fünf Jahre
meiner Amtszeit damit sie keinen Grund
mehr haben keinerlei Grund für die
Extremisten zu stimmen
frankreich wählt ein Präsidenten oder
auch eine Präsidentin vielleicht wird es
ja auch macron zum zweiten Mal 20
Kandidaten stehen beim ersten Durchgang
zur Wahl die meisten sind chancenlos am
Sonntag 14 Tage später wird es den
zweiten Durchgang geben eine Stichwahl
und wer dort hineinkommt das ist noch
unklar das was aber sehr klar ist ist
dass es in Frankreich einen enormen
Rechtsruck gibt über 30 Prozent der
Kandidaten von rechts und rechtsradikal
stehen zur Wahl und haben gute Chancen
auch auf der linken Seite mit Jean-Luc
Milan Show steht ein radikaler mit 15
Prozent also eine deutliche
Radikalisierung und was hört man von
Präsident macron er hält sich weit ab
von den Straßen und Plätzen in Paris und
in Frankreich er ist auf internationalem
Parkett unterwegs und das bei der
Pandemie und vor allen Dingen im Ukraine
Musik und da sammelt er Punkte
was sind die Gründe für den enormen
Erfolg der extremen Kandidaten besonders
auf der rechtsnationalen Seite die
Historikerin der Universität sorbonn
Elena
[Musik]
wenn man sich auf der rechten Seite
anschaut die Kandidatin Kandidaten und
die Zustimmung zu denen dann hat man ja
über 30 Prozent Rechte und
rechtsradikale plus noch einmal etwa 15
Prozent mit melanchance das ist eine
Radikalisierung in Frankreich ist das
ein neues Phänomen das ist ein Phänomen
das im Grunde noch in werden ist das hat
schon vor fünf Jahren angefangen als
Manuel macron in der Mitte sozusagen ein
neues Feld besetzt hat mit der mit der
Auflösung der traditionellen Parteien
aber diese
Umbildung des der Parteienlandschaft ist
noch im Gange und viele würden meinen
dass sie nicht radikal sind wenn sie
marien wählen oder wenn Sie mir doch
schon wählen und das ist eines der
Probleme ich würde sagen dass wir mehr
mit einem mit dem Populismus zu tun
haben als mit der Radikalität denn die
Inhalte die transportiert werden sowohl
links als auch rechts abgesehen von den
wirklich extrem wie sie nur die Klingen
nicht so radikal die sind einfach
demagogisch
macron ist eine Figur in Frankreich die
auf internationalem Parkett schwebt aber
wirkt das in Frankreich nicht das wirkt
aber das ist die Paradoxie an der Figur
von Emmanuel macron er ist erfolgreich
dem Land geht es besser jetzt als vor
der Pandemie hat auch vieles eingesetzt
damit es den Menschen nicht so schlecht
geht aber die Menschen vergleichen sich
nicht mit dem Ausland sondern mit sich
selbst oder mit Ihren Wünschen und vor
allem
nervt er viele Leute das hat etwas mit
seiner Person zu tun mit seiner Haltung
wird von vielen Franzosen wahrgenommen
als ein Repräsentant der
abgehobenen Elite die von den wirklichen
Problemen der Menschen nicht verstehen
würde und das ist das hat wenig zu tun
mit der Art und Weise wie er sich
tatsächlich international bewährt hat
und behauptet hat und aber das würde ich
fast sagen finde die Franzosen normal
dass der französische Staatspräsident
die Position hält aber ja viele meinen
er sei persönlich unerträglich und das
ist sein Problem jetzt bei dieser Wahl
anderthalb Jahre nach der Wahl macrons
im November 2018 Flammen in Paris aber
eigentlich auch überall in Frankreich in
den Städten Proteste auf es waren die
sogenannten Jil Jonen die gelbwesten die
auf die Straße gingen zum Tal zu
Hunderttausenden sie protestierten gegen
einen angeblich vom Volk entfernten
Präsidenten und nicht eingelöste
Reformversprechen von den Jil Jonen sind
keine mehr zu sehen aber die Proteste
gehen weiter auf politischer Ebene sie
dokumentieren sich im Augenblick in
rechten und linken Radikalen und das
macht den Ausgang der Wahl schwer
abschätzbar
dr julia turkel ist bei mir wie kommt es
zu diesem Rechtsruck das ist ja ein
Rechtsruck der vergleichsweise in
anderen Ländern so nicht stattfindet das
ist richtig der erste Rechtsrock fand
wie Sie wissen vor 20 Jahren statt als
der Vater von marien Lippel in die
zweite Runde kam gegen jaakirak und
2007 fünf Jahre danach kam Nicolas
Sarkozy wurde zum Staatspräsidenten
gewählt und hat es eben damals geschafft
die Wähler von Jean-Marie Lippen
anzusprechen und hat dadurch die
französischen konservativen so stark
gemacht und da durch hat er auch den
Sieg davon getragen
als oder seid dem
Sarkozy abgewählt wurde sind die
Nachfolger von Sarkozy bei den
französischen republikern nicht in der
Lage diese Wähler anzusprechen
eigentlich hat die Schwäche der
traditionellen Volksparteien sowohl
rechts als auch links in Frankreich dazu
geführt dass die Populisten jetzt im
Aufwind sind wir haben vor fünf Jahren
erlebt dass Marine lepin mit einem
Programm angetreten ist was am Ende dann
doch den Franzosen
vermittelt hat das wird uns zu kritisch
zu gefährlich sie wollte raus aus der EU
sie wollte raus aus dem Euro sie wollte
raus aus der NATO wir haben jetzt gerade
auch von der Kollegin gehört das ist so
ein bisschen weicher was sie sagt die
zieht sich so ein bisschen zurück und
sagt gar nicht mehr genau was sie will
was wird sie denn tun weil sie genau tun
wird falls sie zur Staatspräsidenten
gewählt werden sollte kann ich Ihnen
nicht sagen ich kann nur sagen was auf
dem Programm steht
vertritt eine ganz andere Vorstellung
der gesellschaftlichen Ordnung
als immer nur zum einen auch eine ganz
andere Rolle von Frankreich sowohl in
der EU als auch in der Welt und das muss
man wirklich betonen
machine Le Pen ist jetzt mit einem
Programm das doch angstschüren könnte
bei den Franzosen wenn sie sich wirklich
damit beschäftigen würden aber wir
wissen ja dass die Außenpolitik Themen
eine geringere Rolle spielen weil bei
dem Wahlkampf und aber wenn sie meint
dass sie eine Abkoppelung von der NATO
jetzt anstrebt dass sie die strategische
Partnerschaft sowohl mit den USA als
auch mit Großbritannien jetzt neu
definieren möchte und dass sie zum
Beispiel auch die
verteidigungspolitischen also die
kooperationsprogramme die Frankreich und
Deutschland
im Bereich der Beteiligung in den
letzten Monaten besprochen und
beschlossen haben in Frage stellen
möchte beziehungsweise einstellen möchte
dann macht es mir doch Sorgen
wenn wir auf die europäische Ebene
schauen vor allen Dingen auf die Ebene
der EU und auch auf die Ebene der NATO
haben wir das Gefühl dass eine
unglaubliche Solidarität entstanden man
steht wirklich zusammen bei diesem Krieg
der in der Ukraine von Russland geführt
wird welchen Einfluss hat denn der Krieg
hier wir haben eine Finanzierung der
Wahlkämpfe
2019/2017 und auch jetzt durch eine sehr
dubiose Form aus Ungarn bzw Russland für
Le Pen ähm Semur hat Putin hochgelobt
hat das überhaupt keinen Einfluss hier
in Frankreich
vor einigen Wochen als der Krieg in der
Ukraine ausbrach hat man auch an den
Umfragewerten von macron zum Beispiel
zum Beispiel festgestellt dass der Krieg
in der Ukraine einen Einfluss haben
könnte und damals
lag macron auch höher als jetzt
einen Tag vor der Wahl vor dem ersten
Wahlgang er lag nämlich bei 30 Prozent
mittlerweile ist er auf 26%
runtergekommen ich würde mal sagen
das hat mittlerweile kaum Einfluss auf
die Wahl oder nur unter dem
Gesichtspunkt das jetzt die Franzosen
sich davor fürchten und das haben wir
gerade angesprochen mit dem Thema
Kaufkraft dass die Spritpreise eben in
die Höhe schießen und dass sie dadurch
auch immer weniger Kaufkraft haben das
gleiche gilt natürlich auch für die
mailpreise und auch für die
Verfügbarkeit in den kommenden Wochen
und Monaten von Rohprodukten
was sich selbstverständlich auf auf das
Leben der Franzosen auch niederschlagen
könnte ganz kurz noch haben wir ein
anderes deutsch-französisches Verhältnis
und ein anderes möglicherweise Europa
bei einer Wahl von Le Pen ein völlig
anderes Verhältnis zu Deutschland um zur
europäischen Integration in jedem Fall
denn alles was macron seit fünf Jahren
vorangebracht hat möchte Martin Lippen
rückgängig machen ich habe Ihnen vorhin
ein paar Beispiele gegeben toll
Dankeschön wir schauen mal auf marien Le
Pen die sich im Laufe ihrer Zeit immer
wieder so ein bisschen politisch
angepasst hat verändert hat und im
Augenblick mit dieser Veränderung da
sagen viele mit diesem Rückzug auf
freundlichere Themen eine gute
Ausgangsposition für die Wahl gesichert
hat
frankreich wählt einen Präsidenten oder
eine Präsidentin sie hat wenig Chancen
ideal Godi Bürgermeisterin von Paris
etwa zwei Prozent könnte sie bekommen
sehr viel mehr Chancen hat
jean-chow auf der linken aber das was
ich historisch andeutet ist auf der
rechten eine massive Zustimmung bei etwa
marien Le Pen die zum letzten Mal 2017
nur knapp hinter macron gelegen hatte
noch radikaler ist Erik Simu er punktet
mit den Themen Rassismus und Immigration
und das hat ihm ein erfolgsbeschwert den
man nicht für möglich gehalten hatte
[Musik]
das bedeutet im Zweifelsfall bis zu 30
Prozent für rechte und rechtsradikale
und das ist ein Problem für den
Präsidenten immer Manuel macron der hält
sich aus den Niederungen des Wahlkampfs
weitgehend raus er ist quasi der
Chefdiplomat der Europäischen Union
zurzeit und damit kann er Punkten aber
die Frage ist ob er in der Stichwahl am
April tatsächlich gegen möglicherweise
die Rechten gewinnen kann der Sieger
steht wohl erst am 24 April fest und die
lepen-biograf in Tanja Kuchenbecker ist
sich sicher es wird knapper als vor fünf
Jahren 2017 wollten die Franzosen am
Ende einer rechtsextreme Präsidentin
Lübben verhindern diesmal auch das kann
sein obwohl wir mittlerweile Umfragen
haben für den zweiten Wahlgang schon und
die sehen Sie jetzt nach besten nach
letzten Ergebnissen bei
47%, was noch mal etwa 13 Prozent mehr
wäre als sie tatsächlich letztes Mal
abgeschnitten hat
das ist da hat sich schon noch mehr
Wählerpotenzial dieses Mal nämlich die
cemurwähler zum Beispiel die dann noch
zu ihr kommen könnten aber auch ein Teil
von der konservativen Valerie Peck BRES
während macron einen Teil picres-wähler
für sich beanspruchen könnte im zweiten
Wahlgang aber seine Wählerpotenzial noch
weiter zuzulegen ist nicht zu
großbecher wir sehen das Bild von 2017
wir haben am gleichen Ort hier in Paris
gestanden und sie haben uns eine kleine
Vorhersage gegeben zu marien Le Pen und
ihren Chancen bei der Wahl das war
spannend sie ist so populär genau aus
dem Grund was sie sagen weil viele Leute
doch in Frankreich Zweifel mittlerweile
an Europa haben auch Abstiegsängste und
sich bei Marine p irgendeiner Form
aufgehoben fühlen die ja an den kleinen
Mann denken will die sagt ich will mit
dem Volk regieren zu sagen sozusagen und
nicht mit der Elite also auch diese
Vorstellung gegen das Establishment
gegen die herrschenden politischen
Parteien zu sein das bringt dir ziemlich
viele Wählerstimmen ein
ja das brachte ihr viele Wählerstimmen
einen schlecht steht sie im Augenblick
auch nicht da was ist das Erfolgsrezept
von ihr im Augenblick thematisch ist ja
nicht sehr viel zu hören
sie hat sich noch weite sie ist noch
weicher geworden als früher noch sanfter
versucht alles was zu einer Polemik
führen könnte zu vermeiden
extreme Äußerungen zu vermeiden und hat
sozusagen diese Enttäuschung die ja ihre
große Strategie eigentlich schon seit
über zehn Jahren ist noch weiter
getrieben man hört sie kaum noch über
emigrationsthemen sprechen auch weniger
über Sicherheit als sonst das waren ja
ihre großen Themen beim letzten Mal
sondern sie geht vielmehr auf das was
die Franzosen den kleinen Mann im Land
interessiert ein nämlich alles was
Kaufkraft ist Energie die Rente das sind
ihre großen Themen und die
stellt sie jede Woche in kleinen
Sitzungen vor so damit sie damit sie im
Gespräch bleibt
neben sozialer Gerechtigkeit ist die
Rente auch für den altklinken
melanchance das große Thema des
Wahlkampfs wenn es nach ihm geht sollen
die Franzosen schon mit 60 in Rente
gehen damit verspricht er sogar noch
mehr als marien Le Pen die ihre
Landsleute weiterhin mit 62 Jahren in
den Ruhestand schicken will Präsident
Makro dagegen besteht auf einer
Verlängerung der Lebensarbeitszeit dass
ich auch der französische Staat seiner
Meinung nach wie die anderen EU-Länder
so früher Renten nicht leisten kann wie
weit sind denn da überhaupt die
Möglichkeit die finanziellen
Möglichkeiten des französischen Staates
gegeben also die Möglichkeiten sind
nicht sehr hoch denn es wurde sicher
jetzt während der covit-krise noch
wieder mächtig verschuldet also die
staatsreserven sind ziemlich leer und
man kann nun nicht irgendwie die
Enkelkinder die Rente ihrer Großeltern
finanzieren lassen schon weil dann
bleibt irgendwann gar nichts mehr übrig
deshalb gehen viele eher offen rechten
Spektrum aber auch Mac dazu über wir ja
auch in vielen anderen europäischen
Ländern das Rentenalter auf anheben
wollen zu anheben zu wollen auf 65
lebenda gegen Silber 62 bleiben und
sogar für Leute die früh angefangen
haben zu arbeiten ist auf 60 senken
genau das sieht macron als einen großen
Kritikpunkt an ihrem Konzept er meint
nämlich dass das nicht zu finanzieren
sei
während macron mit seiner Rolle als
Verhandler mit dem russischen
Präsidenten punktet quasi als
Chefdiplomat der EU geraten die Rechten
in Erklärungsnot in Erik seemoch
gestartet als Shootingstar sahen seine
Anhänger so etwas wie einen
französischen Donald Trump sie muss
selber äußerte seinen Wunsch nach einem
französischen Putin und verlor damit bei
Kriegsbeginn massiven Zustimmung Marine
Le Pen reagierte geschickter trotz ihrer
Bewunderung für Putin in ihrer ersten
wahlkampfvorschüre die schnell wieder
eingestampft wurde zwar ließ sie sich
den Wahlkampf vor fünf Jahren von einer
russischen Bank finanzieren aktuell ist
es eine ungarische ruderte aber stark
zurück beim Thema Putin die Wähler
scheinen ihr die Wände nicht übel zu
nehmen und die Zustimmung zu ihren weich
gewaschenen Positionen steigen
was wird das für eine französische
Republik mit einer möglichen Präsidentin
Lupen das ist sehr schwierig abzusehen
wirtschaftlich natürlich gab es heute
schon die ersten Ausschläge dass man
nämlich befürchtet dass Frankreich
wirtschaftlich schlechter bewertet wird
es gab auch schon Ausschläge an den
Börsen heute sogar
also diese die furchtvolle PEN die man
über die man wochenlang nicht gesprochen
hat scheint jetzt richtig zuzunehmen und
erstmal wird es natürlich auch ein eine
Republik werden wo Europa weniger
wichtig wird also weniger pro-opisch sie
ist für ein Europa der Nationen es
werden möglicherweise wird man auch
wieder merken wie Regelungen gegen
emigrationen verschärft werden
asylregelungen alles was in diese
Richtung geht die ja lebten schon immer
in ihrem Konzept gehabt hat ja und auch
Kontrolle möglich also von
Organisationen kulturellen
Organisationen
politischen Organisationen die dicht in
der Richtung von Leben stehen Butter
Charlie Hebdo entsetzliche Anschläge die
große Furcht in Frankreich in Paris
hinterlassen haben Furcht vor Rassismus
aber auch vor Antisemitismus der
alltägliche Antisemitismus äußert sich
in Brandanschlägen auf Schulen in Morden
und all das das wird noch befördert von
politischen Kandidaten für die Wahl etwa
Eric Semur der offen antisemitisch und
rassistisch Auftritt trotzdem hat er
großen Rückhalt Maja Weber hat
untersucht was da in der französischen
Gesellschaft schiefläuft im Wahlkampf
hat sich einer besonders hervorgetan der
Shootingstar der rechten sozusagen Eric
Semur zehn Prozent hat er in den
Umfragen steht an vierter Stelle und hat
sich besonders mit rassistischen
judenfeindlichen für islamophoben
Aussagen hervorgetan das Problem erik
semour ist selbst Jude und da wird es
kompliziert
die religionsforscherinnen und
Soziologin Martin Coen forscht seit
Jahrzehnten dazu das Phänomen des
Extremisten Semur ist vielfältig
das heißt in der Metro auf der Straße
ist dann jemand entweder ideologisch
antisemitisch oder übellaunlich wie man
sagt und er greift an mit der Faust oder
er klaut einem was oder ruft drecks Jude
das kann es auch sein
ist Vorsitzender der traditionsreichen
Studentenvereinigung jüdischer
Studierender die noch von jüdischen
resistancekämpfern mitten im Zweiten
Weltkrieg gegründet wurde momentan
gleichzeitig gibt es immer noch die
antisemitischen Morde die Anschläge auf
Juden die immer wieder passieren und man
hat den Eindruck dass das nie aufhören
wird dass die Gesellschaft das noch
nicht genug verstanden hat
Frankreich eine antisemitische
Gesellschaft sicher nicht vom Staat her
und nicht überall diesen Antisemitismus
der extremen Rechten die Semur
unterstützt es sind die katholischen
Milieus der extremen identitären Rechten
auf der anderen Seite gibt es in
Frankreich auch den Antisemitismus
vieler arabischer propalästinensischer
Aktivisten mit Migrationsgeschichte
gegen den Generalverdacht gegenüber
Muslimen wie Erik semour in befeuert
selbst macht den Cohen Dialog
auf die islamistischen Terroranschläge
der Vergangenheit aber lassen wenig
Spielraum und ein
fast die Täter von Beleidigungen
Angriffen oder was auch immer an
antisemitischen Akten nicht immer aber
wenn man sie fast dann sind es
mehrheitlich auch wenn es heute sehr
viel weniger geworden ist dann waren es
Muslime
ein Umstand der im Wahlkampf vor allem
von einem Kandidaten instrumentalisiert
wurde dem rechtsextremen Eric simouch
selbst Jude Sohn algerischer Franzosen
der nach eigenen Angaben regelmäßig in
die Synagoge geht allerdings findet er
auch dass sich jüdisches Leben nicht so
sehr in der Öffentlichkeit abspielen
sollte
Cipolla
wenn er Juden ein diskretes auftreten
vorgibt dann macht er das um das auch
den Muslimen vorgeben zu können wir
haben da also ein Antisemitismus beinahe
eine antimuslimische Ideologie einen
anti-muslimischen Rassismus einen
Antisemitismus der ein anti-islamischen
Rassismus transportiert das ist klar
für Martin Coen ein Anlass zu Sorge
nicht für Sie persönlich als Jüdin
sondern besonders für Juden die ihren
Glauben offen zeigen sie findet es mutig
deutlich erkennbar als gläubiger Jude in
Erscheinung zu treten die sogenannten
also rituelle Bänder oder schaufäden zu
tragen
die França
polakipa die Juden die mit den schaufen
dem Hut der Kippa auf die Straße oder in
die Metro gehen sind sehr mutig das
heißt sie sind als Juden erkennbar ich
bin a priori nicht als Jüdin erkennbar
das heißt ich werde nicht unbedingt
angegriffen aber
die Juden die streng gläubiger sind sie
sind sichtbarer und sie sind mutig dass
sie sich so zeigen
dass wir in Frankreich keine Keeper
tragen sollten dieser Satz ist schlimm
ich glaube es gibt Orte an denen es
mutig ist tatsächlich die Kippa zu
tragen aber es gibt eben auch Orte in
Frankreich wo es allein mutig ist
überhaupt jüdisch zu sein in manchen
verteilen in manchen Vierteln mit sehr
hohem Migrationsanteil gibt es keine
jüdischen Schüler mehr in den
staatlichen Schulen kein einzigen also
dort ist es mutig Jude zu sein aber es
ist inakzeptabel dass das solche Orte
gibt nein ich will nicht dass man mutig
sein muss um Jude in Frankreich zu sein
das werde ich nie akzeptieren für Samuel
le jour ist die Antwort auf den
Antisemitismus der Aktivismus der
Kommilitonen
ich glaube trotz allem liegt die Lösung
im aktiven bürgerschaftlichen Engagement
und im Kampf gegen den Rassismus und den
Antisemitismus und da gibt es Probleme
klar
leider gibt es wurden diese Probleme
überall auf der Welt
Erik sinur und andere Extremisten waren
im französischen Wahlkampf ein großes
Thema und viele haben sich gefragt vor
allem in der jüdischen Community und war
erst fehler:innen und erst Wählern wen
kann man überhaupt noch wählen wenn man
einen jüdischen Franzosen nicht wählen
kann
laut dem ältesten in der Runde Eton
benero ist macron der einzige der sich
nicht an diese mytisch geäußert hat
ich glaube schon dass ich für macron
stimmen werde das ist ein bisschen
kompliziert er ist meines Erachtens der
einzige der eben nicht extrem
herüberkommt
ich bin zwar nicht immer einverstanden
mit ihm aber ich würde für ihn stimmen
ähnlich sieht es die andere
zweitwählerin in
der
Wahlen sind wir ein wenig hin und
hergerissen auf der einen Seite haben
wir unsere politische Überzeugung auf
der anderen Seite unsere Werte deren
wegen wir einen bestimmten Kandidaten
wählen insbesondere die Werte des
Judentums die wir bewahren wollen was
die Spannungen in den sogenannten
kartier
benachteiligten Viertel mit hohem
Migrantenanteil angeht sieht die
Soziologin nur eine Möglichkeit für die
Jungs ich würde sagen dass man sich
begegnen muss ich glaube nur daran ich
sage nicht dass es dann eine Garantie
gibt das ist keine Übergriffe mehr gibt
weil es immer ideologisierte
antisemitische Leute geben wird das ist
klar aber man muss mit dem anderen
zusammenkommen das muss man verstärken
vielleicht erscheine ich naiv zu nett
aber sie haben keine Wahl wir müssen da
weitermachen wen die französischen
Jüdinnen und Juden wählen werden werden
sie zum ersten Wahlgang entscheiden
müssen einem werden sie ihre Stimme mit
großer Wahrscheinlichkeit mitgeben davon
haben auch sämtliche Institutionen des
jüdischen Lebens in Frankreich abgeraten
und das ist Erik simuch wir schauen mal
auf die bonlöhe und zwar nicht nur auf
die Bolognese sondern auch auf die
Belleville also auf die Regionen wo die
Menschen nicht sehr viel Geld haben wo
unter anderem unter anderem auch
Migranten unterkommen und wo es offenen
Rassismus und offenen Antisemitismus
gibt
die berühmten Pariser bordieu die
Vorstädte der Hauptstadt sind bei jeder
Wahl in Frankreich ein Thema aber auch
hier mitten im Zentrum von Paris im
Stadtviertel Belleville konzentrieren
sich die Probleme von Migration
Arbeitslosigkeit Armut und Rassismus die
Bevölkerung ist geprägt von Migranten
vor allem aus Nordafrika und aus Asien
hier wurde traditionell links gewählt
sozialistisch oder kommunistisch
Linksaußen Jean-Luc Milan Show konnte
sich hier auf viele Stimmen verlassen
aber politisch hat die Wahl 2017 alles
geändert Michael kokorew beschäftigt
sich seit Jahrzehnten mit den Problemen
der Vorstände
der Sieg von Emmanuel macron 2017 hat
den politischen Raum komplett verändert
hat Stimmen abgesagt sowohl von der
klassischen republikanischen Rechnung
aber auch von der sozialistischen linken
diese beiden Pole die eigentlich das
politische Leben
bestimmen in Frankreich zumindest seit
dem Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs Seite
Befreiung diese beiden Pole sind quasi
implodiert heute ist Frankreich
nicht nach rechts verschoben sondern
sogar zu extremen Recht nehmen während
die linke warte mal atomisiert ist total
zersplittert in belved ist die Armut
sichtbar aber das Viertel wird immer
beliebter die multikulturelle Atmosphäre
zieht viele Künstler an dies fördert
aber auch die Gentrifizierung des
Stadtteils das heißt die Mieten steigen
die ärmere Bevölkerung gerät immer mehr
unter Druck
politisch profitiert davon besonders die
Gruppe der rechten und rechtsextremen
für le Penis Stimmen eher die
einfacheren Menschen während hinter
semour eher Teile der gehobenen
Mittelschicht stehen
das sind nicht die gleichen
Wählerschichten und das ist sehr wichtig
beide Surfen auf dieser Welle des
Gefühls einfach die Nase voll zu haben
und dieses Gefühl war er schon
gewissermaßen durch soziale
Protestbewegungen und die gelbwesten
repräsentiert die Globalisierung fördert
den Nationalismus fördert eine Art
backlash eine Gegenbewegung hin zum
Identitäten die corona-pandemie hat die
Probleme des Viertels weiter verstärkt
und den rechten Parteien Wählerstimmen
zugespielt auch der Kandidat in der
Republikaner Valerie für cresti die
einstierpartei von zachosi die Vorstädte
mit dem sicher reinigen möchte zwar gab
es hier in Bellevue keine Revolten die
in den Vorstädten von Paris aber die
Auflagen der Regierung waren hart die
Ausgangssperren für die Bewohner der
sozialschwachen Viertel mit kleinen
Wohnungen besonders schwer zu ertragen
die meisten Bewohner Leben auf engstem
Raum zusammen und waren mit den
Entscheidungen des Präsidenten nicht
einverstanden als der französische
Präsident für den Bürgern wie zu
Kindern gesprochen hat den man mit denen
man schimpft weil sie ausgehen und damit
die ansteckungsraten steigern zur
gleichen Zeit hat die Kanzlerin Merkel
sich an die deutschen wie an mündige
bürgergewandt auf der einen Seite für
acht auf der anderen Seite Respekt und
das bewirkt einen großen Unterschied in
der gesellschaftlichen Reaktion in
demokratischen Gesellschaften
35.000 Menschen leben in belvederen ihre
Stimmen wenn die Wahl vielleicht nicht
entscheiden aber da die Wahlbeteiligung
wie in den meisten Ländern Europas
weiter abnimmt
handelt es sich für jeden Politiker um
diese Stimme zu kämpfen
also die Wahlbeteiligung wird eine ganz
ganz große Rolle spielen viele sagen
Mörder wird ohnehin macron gewählt das
ist
gefährlich wenn man im Zweifel den
rechten keinen Platz einräumen will das
ist richtig gefährlich wird es nie also
gefährlicher wird es in jedem Fall als
vor fünf Jahren wo der Abstand beim
zweiten Wahlgang ziemlich groß war auch
unerwartet macron er rang damals 66
Prozent der Stimmen und mach ihnen Le
Pen 34 die jetzigen Prognosen sind viel
skeptischer sage ich mal
denn die Schätzungen sind jetzt bei 51
gegen 49
also hat Marine Ben wirklich zu also
gepunktet muss man sagen ich
muss auch sagen macron ist jetzt beim
ersten Wahlgang bei 26 Prozent das sind
natürlich nur Schätzungen aber das
Problem ist im Gegensatz zu Marine dass
er kaum stimmenreserven hat
stimmen wird im zweiten Wahlgang
wahrscheinlich von den Grünen oder von
den Sozialisten wahrscheinlich auch ein
Teil von evalerie Press
die die Kandidatin der konservativen ist
aber das schränkt sich wirklich so ein
und Marine Le Pen es es ist natürlich
alles offen es kommt wir haben drei
populistische Kandidaten je nachdem wer
sich qualifiziert es dürfte Marine Le
Pen sein aber Jean liegt mir auch schon
steht kurz dahinter und hätte eventuell
auch eine gute Chance in die zweite
Runde zu kommen wie sich dann die
Stimmen von melanchance und Samur dann
wie sie überführ werden in welchem
Umfang das ist natürlich jetzt noch
nicht aber wir hatten 2017 ähnliche
Situation wo man auch gesagt hat Marine
und Pen ist ziemlich nah dran und dann
haben sich doch viele Wähler entschieden
erstens mal zur Wahl ohne zu gehen und
zum zweiten zu sagen das ist uns zu
kritisch kann es im zweiten Wahlgang am
eine ähnliche Bewegung noch mal geben
der Unterschied ist aus meiner Sicht
dass die Konservativen damals trotz der
Skandale bei den Republica dass sie so
stark geblieben waren bei vielen genau
der hatte trotzdem Zahl über 20 Prozent
der Stimmen bekommen wo seine
Nachfolgerin als Kandidatin Valerie
press nur kaum zehn Prozent erreicht im
Moment und da hätte macron oder hatte
macron damals auch stimmenreserve über
die er jetzt nicht mehr verfügen kann
halt auch
der Begriff Schicksalswahl ist ein
problematischer Begriff ist es eine
Schicksalswahl ich glaube schon ja
ich bleibe trotzdem optimistisch und als
überzeugter Europäer wünsche ich mir
natürlich dass die EU-Integration
richtig vorangetrieben wird ganz
herzlichen Dank meine Damen und Herren
so weit hier aus Paris zur Wahl in
Frankreich
und in Paris begrüße ich nun meinen
Kollegen Michael krons in der Redaktion
des privaten informationssenders Frances
Michael Manuel macron ist sehr spät in
den Wahlkampf eingestiegen und er hat
das begründet mit der
EU-Ratspräsidentschaft und mit den
intensiven diplomatischen Bemühungen
rund um den Krieg in der Ukraine wird
das von den Franzosen anerkannt
nein eben nicht also es ist glaube ich
eine Idee von ihm gewesen die ab dem 24
Februar funktioniert hat nämlich die
Idee sich als nicht nur Staatspräsident
zu zeigen sondern auch als Chefdiplomat
und Weltpolitiker er hat ja zum Beispiel
von allen europäischen Politikern am
ausführlichsten und häufigsten mit
Wladimir Putin telefoniert hat ihn auch
besucht hat so etwas wie die Aura
verbreitet ich kann möglicherweise hier
im Krieg zu Gesprächen einladen dazu
motivieren und präsentiere mich eben als
jemand der internationalen Politik
schwebt und diejenigen die gesagt haben
ja mal kommen was hast du denn für unser
Land getan was machst du denn im Land
das hat ihn ganz sicher eine Menge
Stimmen gekostet
hat ihm eine Menge Stimmen gekostet man
wirft ihm ja vor dass er über die
innenpolitischen Probleme komplett
hinweg gesehen hat aber er hat in seiner
Präsident hat Präsidentschaft ja schon
was getan haben denn seine Kritiker
Rechte in politischen Probleme hatte
links liegen lassen
naja das ist ja immer subjektiv der
Wähler der hat möglicherweise ja die
offiziellen Zahlen sich nicht angeguckt
wir hatten in dem Beitrag eben die
Kollegin vom Handelsblatt ja noch einmal
klar gemacht hat die Kaufkraft die hier
das Thema überhaupt in politisch ist die
ist eigentlich gestiegen die ist nicht
etwa gefallen so wie von Marine
behauptet wird sondern sie ist gestiegen
eigentlich geht es den Menschen sogar
besser als 2017 als macron an die Macht
kam und insofern ist das natürlich auch
sag mal mal eine subjektive Wahl wie bei
jedem einzelnen nur die objektiven
Zahlen sind andere die objektiven Zahlen
sind andere die Inflationsrate zum
Beispiel in Deutschland ist sehr viel
höher aber nichtsdestotrotz Marine Pen
konnte eben mit dem Thema Kaufkraft
Punkten ein weiteres Thema war ja auch
das Thema Migration was in Frankreich ja
immer wieder ein Thema ist hatte das
macron auch zu wenig im Blick und auch
das Thema Kaufkraft zu wenig im Blick
also ich glaube eher dass es sehr gut
instrumentalisiert worden ist von Lübben
Marie Lübben hat sich extrem
zurückgehalten was die sagen wir mal
Programmatik anbetrifft sie hat gesagt
ach ihr armen Franzosen ihr habt eine so
schlechte Kaufkraft inzwischen wir haben
so ein Problem mit der Migration sie hat
aber nicht vorgestellt und gesagt wie
Sie das ändern will außer was Politiker
ja gerne behaupten ich denke die Steuern
etwa die Mehrwertsteuer oder die Steuern
auf die Energie wie sieht das bezahlen
will da hat macron gesagt das weiß die
ja gar nicht das können wir im
Staatshaushalt überhaupt nicht
hinbekommen sie hat auf die Gefühle der
Menschen gesetzt und sie hat darauf
gesetzt in die sagen wir mal Kampagne
also auf das Land zu fahren und in den
Dörfern mit den Menschen zu sprechen nah
bei ihnen zu sein und das hat gewirkt
Marine Le Pen sagen viele würde sich
weichgespült im im Wahlkampf
präsentieren also Töne wie wir müssen
aus der EU austreten und auch den Euro
wollen wir nicht mehr haben das hören
wir von ihr nicht mehr sie haben es eben
erwähnt sie war auf dem Land sie fordert
mehr Geld für Geringverdiener bessere
Sozialleistungen und sowas allerdings
natürlich nicht für Migranten aber macht
dieses Etwas weichgespieltere Programm
sie eher wählbar
absolut sie hat verstanden dass
derjenige der noch weiter rechts von ihr
steht Eric seemur der Anfang ist ja
einen großen Erfolg gelandet hat ein
Überraschungssieger war für viele
wählbar plötzlich weil er sagt es muss
alles anders werden wir müssen die
Migration komplett stoppen der sehr
antisemitisch auch aufgetreten ist der
war so weit rechts dass sie schon fast
in der Mitte zu sein schien und das hat
sie ausgenutzt und hat damit auch den
Eindruck vermittelt ich bin wählbar sie
hat auch selber gesagt ich bin doch
jemand der Präsidentin sein kann das ist
doch gar kein Problem die wirklich
entscheidenden programmatischen Vorgaben
etwa was ist denn mit der EU was will
sie denn in der EU ja da hat sie gesagt
ja ja ich bleibe in der EU mit
Frankreich aber wir müssen da ein
anderes System schaffen gegenüber
Brüssel wir müssen mehr
Nationalstaat haben das hat sie so
programmatisch gar nicht sauber
kontrolliert trotzdem sagen die Leute ja
macron war nicht auf dem Land er ist nur
zwischen Moskau und Paris hin und her
geflogen dass der hat sich nicht um uns
gekümmert wir waren am Moor macht in
Paris und haben an einem sehr sonnigen
Tag heute in einem Wahlbüro einmal
gedreht und haben dort gefragt die
Wähler was hat sie denn eigentlich
beschäftigt bei der Wahl
das ist die Stimmkarte für Emanuel
macron gewesen dann folgen marien le
pellen und Erik seemur auf der rechten
und die Franzosen wählen hier einmal
macht bis 20 Uhr und wir haben einmal
gefragt was bewegt die Franzosen bei
dieser Wahl was ist Ihnen wirklich
wichtig
ich habe wirklich alles aus nächster
Nähe verfolgt Frankreich Europa alle
Themen ich bin wirklich sehr auf dem
Laufenden ja es ist wichtig für
Frankreich für Deutschland für Europa
für die Enkelkinder für die Urenkel auch
ihre Urenkel ja ich bin eine Uroma und
darum ist die Wahl wichtig
für mich gehen die extreme gar nicht so
einfach ist das ist das das wichtigste
jetzt hier für mich ja der Aufbau
Europas
und meinte das war natürlich gewinnen
der muss eine europäischer Kandidat sein
was sind für Sie die Gründe für ihre
Wahlentscheidung und für die Beteiligung
an der Wahl geht es ihnen
um die Idee der europäischen Einheit
geht es ihnen auch um die Beziehung
zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich
ja absolut
um die europäische Integration
vorzusetzen bin ich Höhe eine stärkeren
Integration für stärkere europäische
Entscheidungen das ist ja der Gedanke
von Monsieur macron ja ich glaube schon
den entscheidenden Faktor für den
Wahlsieg den könnte es heute dadurch
geben dass viele Franzosen zu Hause
bleiben sie gehen nicht ins Wahllokal
und wählen nicht das sind einmal die
Franzosen die davon ausgehen dass macron
gewinnen könnte es sind aber auch die
Franzosen die sagen es ist ja eigentlich
ganz egal wer gewählt wird wir wollen da
nicht mitmachen es gibt eine große
Unzufriedenheit und die könnte sich sehr
deutlich noch einmal in sehr stark
steigenden
Nichtwähler Zahlen äußern ich wähle
nicht aus meinen persönlichen Interessen
sondern mir geht es um das Gemeinwohl es
geht nicht nur darum was ich will
sondern es geht darum was für alle am
besten ist
das war einmal machtre das ist ein eher
bürgerliches Viertel also das sind nicht
unbedingt diejenigen die jetzt sagen wir
wollen aus Protest Marine Le Pen wählen
oder ihre hoch das muss man dazu sagen
und damit zurück nach Bonn zu Michaela
Kosta ja vielen Dank Michael krons für
diese interessanten Einblicke wir wollen
uns schauen wie die letzten Tage des
Wahlkampfs waren der Freitag Nacht zu
Ende ging denn der letzte Tag vor der
Wahl ist traditionell wahlkampffrei
meine Kollegin Anne Arendt hat sich die
letzten Auftritte von Emanuel macron
Marine Le Pen und im linken Kandidaten
Jean-Luc Miller Show angeschaut
Momente in denen Emmanuel macron den Weg
zum Volk suchte waren im Wahlkampf war
auch daher gilt der Präsident vielen als
und nahbar nun wird er um das Vertrauen
für eine weitere Amtszeit und verteidigt
seine Politik
meine Reformen haben Fortschritt
gebracht an dem Tandem liberalisieren
und schützen halte ich fest und auch
daran dass wir ein System haben dass die
Franzosen in Krisenzeiten absichert
doch längst nicht alle nehmen ihm die
Rolle des Beschützers ab sie sorgen sich
vor weiter steigenden Kosten für Energie
und für Lebensmittel haben Angst vor dem
Abstieg
ich habe Familie bin 46 Jahre alt und
kann nicht von meinem Einkommen leben
finden Sie das normal
zur Kaufkraftsteigerung haben wir 20
Milliarden Euro ausgegeben richtig aber
ich habe nichts davon weil ich keine
Ansprüche habe ich
und so holt mariende Pen immer mehr auf
setzt auf die Stimmen der unzufriedenen
und jener die den Verlust der
französischen Werte fürchten vor allem
auf dem Land erhält sie viel Zuspruch
mein Gegner heißt Emmanuel macron ihn
will ich besiegen für Frankreich
es ist der dritte Anlauf der
Rechtspopulistin laut Umfragen war sie
nie so nah am Präsidentenamt sie gibt
sich inzwischen weniger radikal doch im
Kern bleibt sie ihrem nationalistischen
Kurs treu der folgenreich wäre für
Europa und für die deutsch-französische
Zusammenarbeit
[Applaus]
entweder werden wir in einer
globalisierten Welt deren Vorreiter die
Europäische Union ist untergehen
oder wir stärken die französische Nation
die die unseren schützt
und noch ein antieuropäer mobilisiert
die Massen jollyk melanchance ist der
chancenreichste unter den zahlreichen
linken Kandidaten sein Programm mehr
Mindestlohn Rente schon ab 60 und
Austritt aus der NATO er wird auf Platz
drei gesehen nach marien Lübben und
Emmanuel macron vieles deutet derzeit
auf ein Duell der beiden in der
Stichwahl hin mit einem sehr knappen
Vorsprung für macron den Reformer den
Pro Europäer
es ist der Kampf des Fortschritts gegen
den Rückzug es ist der Kampf des
europäischen Patriotismus gegen die
Nationalisten
in zwei Wahlrunden entscheidet
Frankreich nun wer als Präsident oder
Präsidentin im elisepalast residieren
wird es ist auch eine Entscheidung über
die Zukunft Europas
und ich begrüße nun sehr herzlich bei
uns Ronja Kempin von der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik in Berlin sie
beschäftigt sich vor allem mit dem
deutsch-französischen Beziehungen in
verteidigungs- und Sicherheitsfragen
aber auch mit der Rolle der rechten und
des Populismus in Frankreich herzlich
willkommen Frau kampin leider konnten
sie ja nicht zu uns ins Studio kommen
dann merken wir wie sehr die Pandemie
unser tägliches Leben nach wie vor noch
beeinflusst und bestimmt
ja das tut mir auch sehr leid ich grüße
trotzdem ganz ganz herzlich aus Berlin
ich freue mich dass ich auf diese Art
bei Ihnen sein darf freue ich mich auch
vor Kempin ich würde zunächst gerne auf
den Präsidenten schauen
zu der seit Jahren spielenden Pandemie
die wir gerade schon erwähnt haben kam
auch nur noch der Krieg in der Ukraine
hinzu und das genau zu Beginn der EU
Ratspräsidentschaft Frankreichs hat
macron seine Aufgabe da gut gemacht er
hat ja lange und oft mit Putin
telefoniert wir sahen ihm überall auf
dem
internationalen Parkett wie kam das an
bei den Franzosen
ja man muss schon sagen dass das auf
oder sich dieser Effekt des
diplomatischen der Diplomatie abgenutzt
hat im Wahlkampf also wenn wir nur auf
den Wahlkampf schauen müssen wir sehen
dass unmittelbar nach Ausbruch des
Krieges tatsächlich die
Beliebtheitswerte des Präsidenten in die
Höhe gestellt ist sind lag bei 31
Prozent das waren Werte die er bis dato
nicht erreicht hatte aber je mehr er
eben sich auf dem diplomatischen Parkett
umgetrieben hat und je mehr er eben wie
sie es in ihrem Beitrag auch schon
angedeutet hatten eben in Moskau
unterwegs war sehr viel nach Brüssel
gereist ist die europäische Ebene
versucht hat eben zu bespielen als
EU-Ratspräsident je mehr ist den
Franzosen aufgefallen ja wo ist denn
eigentlich unser Präsident was tut er
für uns und ich glaube das ist ihm
tatsächlich
also ein Stück weit auf die Füße
gefallen das kam nicht gut an bei seinen
WählerInnen und wählen hier ist er so
ein bisschen
Opfer seiner eigenen
Dramaturgie gewesen er wollte ja
unbedingt auch die europäische
Ratspräsidentschaft während des
Wahlkampfes haben er wollte die schönen
Bilder er wollte sich als Staatenlenker
präsentieren und er hat dabei vergessen
dass die Bevölkerung in Frankreich von
ihrem Präsidenten eben auch Antworten
auf ihre ganz alltäglichen Fragen Nöte
und Sorgen erwartet wenn wir dann noch
mal fünf Jahre zurückschauen als er
angetreten ist das war ja ganz neue Töne
die er da auch angeschlagen hat und
dafür ist er letztendlich auch gewählt
worden Stichworte waren da schlanker
Staat um der Wirtschaften ein Stück
werden weit mehr Luft zu verschaffen er
wollte eine Arbeitsmarktreform
durchsetzen Steuerlast senken eine
Rentenreform wollte auch noch anpacken
was hat er denn davon umgesetzt
also man muss schon sagen dass er viel
umgesetzt hat die Bilanz von Emmanuel
macron ist eigentlich eine gute Bilanz
ich glaube das wäre falsch ihm da in
Abrede zu stellen dass er nichts
geschafft hat also er ist angetreten
2017 als Frankreich wirtschaftspolitisch
der kranke Mann Europas war und die
Arbeitslosigkeit war sehr hoch sie lag
zwischen 12 und 15 Prozent gerade bei
den Jugendlichen laxiver über 25 Prozent
viele junge Menschen haben ihre Zukunft
gar nicht mehr in Frankreich gesehen
haben kurze befristete Arbeitsverträge
oft nur von einem halben Jahr
bekommen und da hat er eben mit seiner
doch sehr
für viele Franzosen rabiaten Reform des
Arbeitsmarktes aber doch dafür gesorgt
dass in Frankreich die Arbeitslosigkeit
auf 7% runtergegangen ist in den fünf
Jahren seiner Arbeit seiner Amtszeit
verloren hat er 1,2 Millionen neue Jobs
geschafft geschaffen in Frankreich sie
haben es auch schon in ihrem Einspieler
gesagt die Kaufkraft ist entgegen der
weitläufigen Meinung der Bevölkerung
gestiegen die Löhne sind in Frankreich
gestiegen aber er hat eben diese
Reformen oft mit einer sehr
überheblichen mit mit einer
selberheblichen Art und Weise sozusagen
verbunden er hat die Bevölkerung nicht
mitgenommen sie ist ja gegen ihn massiv
auf die Straße gegangen erinnern Sie
sich an die Generalstreiks im Winter
2019 als er eben tatsächlich die
Rentenreform
angekündigt hat die hat er dann
verschoben dann kam die Pandemie dann
ist sie auf Eis gelegt worden aber er
ist eben oft mit der Brechstange
sozusagen nach vorne geprescht und hat
damit viele Wählerinnen und Wähler vor
den Kopf gestoßen er hat ja auch auf
sehr
ja herablassende Art und Weise die
gelbwesten betitelten gesagt also das
sind eigentlich nicht die Franzosen die
wir haben die alte dreckige
dieselschleuder noch fahren und sich
jetzt darüber beschweren dass wir um den
Klimawandel voranzutreiben eine Steuer
auf fossile Kraftstoffe erheben also das
sind dann sozusagen ist dann das andere
Gesicht der Amtszeit Emmanuel macrons
dass wir nicht vergessen dürfen bei
allen Erfolgen sind die
sind die Nöte die Sorgen der
Französinnen Franzosen bei ihm nie sehr
auf offene Ohren gestoßen sie sprechen
es gerade an er hat eine gute Bilanz
dennoch offensichtlich haben ihm die
Franzosen das nicht gedankt ich würde
gern noch mal auf die gelbfesten
Proteste ein Stück weit eingehen er
musste ja aufgrund dieser massiven
Proteste von denen wir hier in
Deutschland ja auch allen Teilen gehört
haben ja auch einige seiner
Reformvorhaben zurücknehmen also würden
Sie sagen er hat das ganze dann
letztendlich doch ganz gut gemanagt weil
er es zurückgenommen hat und haben diese
Proteste ihnen irgendwie geprägt hat er
seine Politik verändert
ich hatte nicht den Eindruck dass er
seine Politik verändert hat muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen er hat ja
möglicherweise auch wir werden es
nachher sehen in diesem Wahlkampf einen
ganz entscheidenden taktischen Fehler
begangen als seine Zustimmungswerte
ebenso hoch waren nach Beginn des
russischen Angriffs auf die Ukraine
schien er sich so sie sicher zu sein
dass er ja angekündigt hat also wenn ich
wiedergewählt werde dann hebe ich das
Renteneintrittsalter von 62 auf 65 Jahre
an und all die zwei Millionen
Französinnen Franzosen die im Moment
Grundsicherung beziehen also bei uns
wäre das Hartz IV die müssen Pflicht
verpflichtend 15 Stunden er pro Woche
arbeiten ansonsten
verlieren sie den Anspruch auf diese
Grundsicherung also da ist er wieder
sehr kompromisslos sozusagen
vorgeprescht und damit hat er glaube ich
viel Kapital
auch wieder sozusagen verspielt nach den
gelbwesten hat er der Bevölkerung
suggeriert ich höre auf auf euch er hat
diese ganz große Bürgerbeteiligung ins
Leben gerufen er ist viel durchs Land
gefahren er hat viele Versammlungen
abgehalten er hat wirklich das Ohr
sozusagen am Volk gehabt nur er hat aus
diesen Reformvorschlägen fast gar nichts
gemacht die erarbeitet worden sind und
den gleichen Vorwurf muss er sich
gefallen lassen mit Blick auf die
bürgerkonvente für das Klima er hatte ja
2020 die Wahlen Kommunalwahlen gegen die
Grünen sehr stark verloren in etwa die
gleiche Wählerschaft die auch seine
stammwellerschaft ist hatte sich
abgewandt den Grünen zugewendet nach der
gesagt Mensch okay dann bin ich euch ein
wir machen einen Bürgerkonvent für das
Klima 150 BürgerInnen Bürger sind nach
einem Zufallsprinzip ausgewählt worden
und haben eben über mehrere Monate einen
ein Programm entwickelt entworfen wie
Frankreich eben sehr schnell
klimafreundlich werden erkannt und auch
von diesen Reformvorschlägen hat er fast
nichts umgesetzt und das hinterlässt
natürlich bei der Bevölkerung auch
wieder ein etwas schales Gefühl also
wenn es ihm nutzt dann befragt er uns
dann befriedet er die Stimmung an nimmt
den Druck ein wenig aus dem Kessel er
gewinnt so Zeit aber
unsere Vorschläge sind für ihn für seine
Politik doch sehr wenig maßgeblich und
ich glaube auch das ist ein Bild was ich
von ihm in den letzten fünf Jahren doch
in der Bevölkerung auch ein Stück weit
festgesetzt hat
wir kommen gleich noch mal zu Ihnen Frau
rempin wir würden jetzt gerne noch mal
mit einem Beitrag erstmal auf die
extreme Rechte in Frankreich schauen das
sind nämlich vor allem die extremen
Rechten die den Präsidenten das Leben
schwer machen namentlich ist es Marine
Le Pen die zum dritten Mal als
Präsidentschaftskandidatin antritt aber
es ist auch Eriks demur der mit
radikalen Thesen und Provokationen
versucht immer wieder zu punkten mein
Kollege Thomas Walde hat die Rechten im
Wahlkampf begleitet
extreme Rechte nennen Franzosen marien
Le Pen und ihre Partei wegen ihrer
Positionen ich will den Franzosen ihr
Land zurückgeben ich will Ihnen Ihre
Sicherheit wiedergeben ihr Geld die
Früchte ihre Arbeit
einen EU-Austritt Frankreichs fordert
Leben nicht mehr um auch für weniger
radikale wählbar zu sein das hat eine
Flanke geöffnet nein zum Rassismus
begleitet von Protesten traf sich lepenz
Konkurrent der wegen Hetze verurteilte
Erik Semur mit Anhängern mit radikaleren
Tönen versuchte zu übertreffen
wir retten die Kaufkraft der Franzosen
indem wir die Finanzierung der
Einwanderung auf unsere Kosten beenden
wir müssen aufhören eure leere Taschen
zu greifen um die ganze Welt zu ernähren
solche Töne haben folgen viele
Frankreich weniger europafahnen auch bei
den Konservativen sie versuchen sich mit
deutlichen Ansagen vor allem zur inneren
Sicherheit nach ganz rechts und
angreifbar zu machen
[Applaus]
Chefs die Gauner die Dealer die
Verbrecher die Hassprediger sie werde
ich behelligen und ihnen die
Bürgerrechte streitig machen ich rücke
mit dem Dampfstrahler an dem Kärcher
Emanuel macron unterscheidet sich mit
pro-europäischen Aussagen und fordert
gleichzeitig Grenzen stärker zu sichern
auch um den rechten Angriffsfläche zu
nehmen denn deren Töne prägen durchaus
das politische Klima in Frankreich
[Applaus]
das würde ich gerne mit Ihnen noch ein
Stück weit vertiefen marine Le pent
tritt nun zum dritten Mal als
Präsidentschaftskandidatin ein und wir
sehen dass sie sehr viel gemäßigte
Auftritt als sie das in ihren letzten
Wahlkämpfen getan hat sie spricht nicht
mehr vom EU-Austritt oder dass man den
Euro hinter sich lassen müsste sie tritt
viel mehr so als Vertreterin der kleinen
Leute auf ist sie dadurch tatsächlicher
gemäßigter und wie schätzen Sie Ihre
Chancen ein
also Marine ist von der Programmatik her
kein Stück gemäßigter sie ist genauso
extrem wie sie die letzten beiden
Wahlkämpfe über war also wenn wir durch
ihr Programm gehen dann gebe ich Ihnen
recht sie hat ein paar Spitzen
herausgenommen sie möchte keinen
Referendum mehr über den Austritt ihres
Landes aus dem Euro abhalten sie möchte
Frankreich generell nicht mehr aus der
Europäischen Union heraus führen aber
wenn der beispielsweise auf die
Beziehungen zu Deutschland blicken die
ihr vorschweben dann dann muss man doch
sagen
sie stellt fest in ihrem Programm das
ist
unüberbrückbare ideologische Differenzen
wirtschaftliche Differenzen gibt sie
will die Zusammenarbeit die in den
letzten Jahren mühevoll aufgebaut worden
ist zwischen den beiden Ländern in der
sicherheits- und Verteidigungspolitik
beenden sie unterstützt nicht länger
einen deutschen Sitz im ständigen
Sicherheitsrat der Vereinten Nationen
insgesamt will sie Deutschland Schwächen
und auch mit der Europäischen Union
legt sie sich letztendlich ganz ganz
deutlich an das sehen wir insbesondere
beim Thema Immigration
Sozialleistungen will sie den Franzosen
vorbehalten
Immigranten sollen nicht mehr in den
Genuss von Sozialleistungen kommen keine
Mietzuschüsse keine Familienbeihilfen in
Frankreich erhalten auch EU-Ausländer
will sie den Zugang zu Sozialleistungen
erschweren erst nach fünf Jahren voller
Tätigkeit Berufstätigkeit in Frankreich
sollen diese Leistungen ausgezahlt
werden können an EU-Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern all das widerspricht natürlich
fundamental den europäischen Gesetzen
die wir über die letzten Jahre
vereinbart haben also das zeigt
eigentlich vom Programm genauso extrem
geblieben ist wie in den letzten zehn
Jahren ich glaube aber hören sie nicht
unterbrechend
dann versucht sie sicher besonders
volksnahe zu geben also ihr Wahlkampf
fand vor allen Dingen auf dem Land statt
die auf dem Land fühlen sich sowieso
immer ein Stück weit zurückversetzt wenn
sie sich mit Paris oder mit den großen
Städten vergleichen sie hat dem ganzen
so eine nationale Präferenz gegeben für
die für die wirtschaftlich schwächeren
bei wem kommt das letztendlich an kommt
es bei den Menschen auf dem Land an
fühlen Sie sich ein Stück weit abgehängt
und sie fängt die auf
ja also das war schon ihr Erfolgsrezept
eigentlich im letzten Wahlkampf 2017
dass sie sich tatsächlich als die
Fürsprecherin der kleinen Leute
sozusagen sieht wie
zieht ganz stark darauf ab tatsächlich
den Menschen auf dem Land das Gefühl
zurückzugeben ihr werdet gesehen ihr
werdet nicht länger vergessen wir müssen
dazu wissen dass der Unterschied
zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich
derjenige ist dass der ländliche Raum in
Frankreich nicht kleiner wird der
schwindet nicht also die Städte gewinnen
nicht zugunsten des Landes die ländliche
Bevölkerung bleibt in etwa gleich groß
aber über die letzten Jahre hat gerade
im ländlichen Frankreich ein massiver
Rückbau staatlicher Dienstleistungen
stattgefunden das betrifft
Dienstleistungen wie die Post
alles was wir unter das Stichwort
öffentliche Daseins Fürsorge sozusagen
setzen
das bedeutet für die Menschen auch dass
es eine ganz geringe Dichte an
hausärztlicher Versorgung
gibt dem ist in Frankreich auf dem Land
oft nur halb so stark ausgeprägt wie in
Deutschland und das sind eben diese
Gruppierungen an an Wählerinnen und
Wähler die gerne auf dem Land bleiben
wollen weil sie sich dort eine
Lebensstandard noch leisten können den
sie sich in der Stadt nicht leisten
können und wollen also sich auch den
Werten verhaftet fühlen auf die geht sie
gezielt zu unserer ich vergesse euch
nicht ich bin für euch da ich bringe
euch eure Post zurück ich bringe euch
eure Polizei zurück ich bringe euch die
Grundschulen zurück ich bring euch den
Staat zurück ihr seid nicht vergessen
das kommt tatsächlich bei den an das
kommt auch an bei Arbeiterinnen und
Arbeitern einfachen ArbeiterInnen und
Arbeiten die im frauen-national heute
heißt der jahresraum Lemon national ist
schon seit einigen Jahren die politische
Heimat sehen und nicht länger wir haben
bei den Kommunisten oder bei den
Sozialisten die diese
Bevölkerungsschicht traditionell ja
repräsentiert hat oder würde ganz gerne
einen O-Ton von Emanuel macron noch mal
abspielen den er 2017 unmittelbar nach
seiner Wahl gesagt hat zu marien Lippen
vielen Dank meine Freunde
du willst auch klar und ich möchte auch
ein Wort richten an diejenigen die heute
für Madame Leben gestimmt haben nein
nein nein Boot sie nicht aus pfeift sie
nicht aus sie haben sie haben heute zum
Ausdruck gebracht dass sie zornig sind
dass sie verzweifelt sind
manchmal auch haben sie Überzeugungen
zum Ausdruck gebracht aber ich
respektiere diese Menschen ich werde
aber alles tun während der fünf Jahre
meiner Amtszeit damit sie keinen Grund
mehr haben keinerlei Grund für die
Extremisten zu stimmen
ja es hat sich in dem Lager der
Extremisten doch noch insofern einiges
getan weil noch ein viel radikalerer
nämlich aufgetreten ist und das ist Erik
Semur
Populist ein scharf mache der sich einer
Nostalgie für ein Frankreich bedientes
offensichtlich ankommt bei wem kommt das
an und was sagt das über die
Gesellschaft in Frankreich aus
also Erik sie nur hat eine ganz andere
Wählerschicht im Blick als das marine
tut wir hatten schon gesagt Marine Le
Pen hat eher die kleineren Leute wie man
so schön sagt im Blick die einfachen
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer die
am Ende des Monats nur noch schwer über
die Wunden kommen finanziell gezielt auf
Leute ab die in armen Landstrichen
Frankreichs eben auch
leben wo das Lohngefälle oft 10 bis 18
Prozent niedriger ist im Vergleich zum
Beispiel zum Pariser Raum und Erik sinur
zielt tatsächlich eher auf eine
bourgeoise also eine sehr gut
bürgerliche
französische Rechte ab die eben Algerien
noch nachhängt also der kolonialen
Vergangenheit des Landes der
Weltmachtstellung des Landes und die
eben Angst hat dass das Land überfremdet
wird die ganz gezielt eben auch eine
Ausländerfeindlichkeit kultiviert ohne
sie
so zur Schau zu tragen wie das marine Le
Pen lange gemacht hat obgleich sie nur
sie haben es auch schon gesagt ja des
öfteren mittlerweile verurteilt worden
ist wegen der Anstiftung zum Rassenhass
in wir wollen mal einmal einen Blick
darauf werfen welche Bedeutung die
Wahlen in Frankreich denn auch für das
Ausland haben nämlich für Washington
London und Brüssel
in den USA wird die französische
Präsidentschaftswahl vor allem mit Blick
auf den Krieg in der Ukraine beurteilt
Media ist die Wahl zwar wenig präsent
aber für die Regierung von US-Präsident
Joe Biden hat sie durchaus Bedeutung und
zwar aus zwei Gründen erstens aus Sicht
vieler hier in Washington hat Emanuel
macron der französische Präsident eine
Führungsrolle in Europa übernommen vor
allem seit Angela Merkel nicht mehr
Kanzlerin von Deutschland ist umso
wichtiger ist das jetzt im Ukraine Krieg
dort hat macron auch eine
Schlüsselposition in den Verhandlungen
übernommen aus Sicht der USA ist macron
einer der wichtigsten wenn nicht gar der
wichtigste Ansprechpartner in der EU und
innerhalb der NATO würde macron
abgewählt könnte das auch die
Geschlossenheit des Westens gegenüber
Russland gefährden und das will man in
Washington unbedingt vermeiden
zweitens mit Sorge wird auch die
Aufholjagd der Rechtspopulistin Marine
Le Pen beurteilt eine französische
Präsidentin Le Pen mit ihrem Anti EU und
antinatokurs und ihrer in der
Vergangenheit Russland freundlichen
Haltung wäre ein Schreckenszenario für
viele in den USA
also wenn die Franzosen zur Wahlurne
gehen werden in Washington sicher viele
macron die Daumen drücken das Vereinigte
Königreich und Frankreich das ist eine
alte Hassliebe diese ewige Rivalität
werden nun die größere Großmacht in
Europa ist in den vergangenen Jahren
überwogen die negativen Seiten das
Verhältnis gilt als Ark strapaziert
erstens natürlich der brexit Frankreich
gilt hier in London als der Scharfmacher
in Sachen EU-Austritt das Land mit der
härtesten anti-brexit-haltung in Europa
zweitens der orchestil zumindest die
sicherheitszusammenarbeit hatte in den
brexitjahren keinen Schaden genommen und
dann das Bretten und Amerikaner drängen
Frankreich im vergangenen Herbst aus
einem lange vereinbarten Milliarden
U-Boot rüstungsstil mit Australien raus
verkünden im selben Atemzug eine neue
Dreier militär-allianz Paris war da mehr
als nur verschnupft und drittens die
kanalbootkrise die Zahl flüchtender die
sich in gummiboten von der französischen
Küste nach Großbritannien aufmachen ca
40 Kilometer über den Ärmelkanal hat in
den vergangenen Jahren stark zugenommen
obwohl so die britische Sicht London
Millionen überweise damit die
französische Polizei das verhindere viel
Streit die gefühlte politische Breite
des Ärmelkanals ist deutlich größer
geworden doch die große Hoffnung dass
mit dem ukrainekrieg der Renaissance der
NATO ja da vielleicht der Graben wieder
zugeschüttet werden kann mit einem
konzilianteren Präsidenten macron in
seiner zweiten Amtszeit über eine Marine
Pen an der Spitze Frankreich die ja
nicht nur der EU sehr skeptisch
gegenüber steht sondern auch der NATO
darüber denkt hier noch niemand
ernsthaft nach getreu dem pragmatischen
britischen Ansatz wie cross the bridge
from me get there damit beschäftigen wir
uns wenn es wirklich dazu kommen sollte
natürlich liegt der Fokus in der
Europäischen Union auch auf der
ukraine-krise und auf der Frage wie die
Europäer putinskrieg stoppen könnten
außerdem war man sich insgeheim ja schon
sicher dass Emanuel macron das Rennen in
Frankreich schon machen würde aber in
den letzten Tagen steigt die Nervosität
hier in Brüssel weil es immer mehr
Umfragen gibt die ein enges Kopf an Kopf
Rennen zwischen Emmanuel macron und
Marine Le Pen Voraussagen eine hohe
französische Diplomatin warnte die EU
letzte Woche und sagte ihr solltet euch
mehr Sorgen machen als ihr es bislang
tut ein Sieg von Marine Le Pen könne sie
nicht ausschließen natürlich hofft man
in Brüssel auf eine Wiederwahl von
Emmanuel macron seine Politik ist pro
europäisch und der hat versucht als
europäischer Führer in die Lücke zu
stoßen die Angela Merkel hinterlassen
hat die Wahl von Marine Le Pen wäre für
Europa eine Katastrophe sie steht für
eine Europa kritische Haltung sie nicht
enge Beziehungen zu Viktor Orban und zu
Vladimir Putin sie will das Frankreich
aus der nato-austritt und ist natürlich
auch gegen eine gemeinsame europäische
Flüchtlingspolitik würde marine Le
pent-präsidentin von Frankreich dann
wäre eine deutsch-französische
Zusammenarbeit oder auch ein
gesamteuropäischer Zusammenhalt wie er
im Moment in der ukraine-krise besteht
wohl unmöglich macron wird in Brüssel
vor allem dafür geschätzt dass er
Frankreich pro europäisch ausgerichtet
hat obwohl er wie alle französischen
Präsidenten in erster Linie auch in
Europa französische Politik gemacht hat
das sieht man bei der Flüchtlingspolitik
bei der er oft mehr Dinge angekündigt
als dann tatsächlich umgesetzt hat das
sieht man auch bei den Maßnahmen gegen
den Klimawandel bei denen Frankreich
nicht immer an vorderster Front mit
dabei ist aber macron hat gerade in der
flüchtlingskrise eine europäische
Führungsrolle eingenommen und es würde
die Europäische Union extrem Schwächen
wenn macron jetzt von der Bühne abtreten
wichtigste
Frau Kempin wir haben es gerade gehört
es wurde die EU auch Schwächen wenn
macron abtreten würde er hat sich ja so
ein Stück weit auch als Visionär für die
Weiterentwicklung Europas einen Namen
gemacht sehr früh in seiner
Präsidentschaft da hat er mit Ideen und
Szenarien für Europa versucht zu punkten
wir haben es gerade von der
Korrespondenten gehört aber ich würde es
von Ihnen auch gerne noch mal wissen als
Einschätzung wie wichtig ist es für die
EU das macron tatsächlich gewinnt oder
könnt ihr die EU auch sagen naja
Frankreich ist ein Land von inzwischen
da macht es auch nichts wenn wir eine
Marine lepenne haben die können wir
schon aushalten
nein also das wäre glaube ich ein sehr
vermessener Satz es wäre schon ein ein
großer Schock das muss man und zwar für
Haft sagen Frankreich ist gründungsland
der Europäischen Union und in einem
gründungsland der Europäischen Union
plötzlich eine rechtsextreme
antieuropäische Kandidatin als
Präsidentin zu haben das würde doch den
europäischen Integrationsprozess zum
Erliegen
bringen die demokratischen Kräfte in der
Europäischen Union werden extrem
geschwächt wir haben es schon gesagt
Marine Le Pen sieht sich in einer Linie
politisch mit Viktor Orban mit der
Regierung in Polen sie will also das
nationale Recht deutlich über das
europäische Recht stellen also
Fortschritte wären hier überhaupt nicht
mehr möglich und Europa wäre extrem
geschwächt in diesen Zeiten in den Musik
wieder in Europa herrscht also das wäre
schon ein ganz gravierender Einschnitt
den wir nicht einfach fünf Jahre
aussitzen könnten
vielen Dank soweit in ein paar Minuten
schließen die Wahllokale in Frankreich
und deshalb werden wir uns jetzt zu den
Kollegen von François aufschalten im
öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender in
Frankreich
und ja
Herr Präsident ist immer noch im elisee
und wartet auf seine trifft später erst
seine Anhänger ja der Präsident ist noch
hier der studiert alle vor Wahlprognosen
er ist von seinen engsten Beratern
umgeben und holt sie noch ein paar
politische Ratschläge alle Minister alle
Anhänger sind in der Porto versai wo der
Präsident und Kandidat nach der
Verkündung der ersten Hochrechnung der
Ergebnisse sich hin begeben wird also
gegen 21 Uhr wird er dort sprechen er
wird also
dort sprechen wir die Minuten ticken
runter von der Uhr
jetzt haben wir gerade plötzlich ein
Netzproblem dann treffen uns erstmal mit
an zu viel Natalie ja die Spannung
steigt nur noch wenige Minuten dann
wissen wir mehr
hier haben wir schon die ersten Gäste
hier
sehen Sie unsere Gäste und die werden in
den nächsten Monaten Minuten natürlich
reagieren
wir müssen uns jetzt beruhigen
ja
gleich wissen wir mehr melanchance
wer wird in die Stichwahl kommen nun
Jeanette Müller hat eine
lebendige Kampagne geführt und er war
auf dem vierten Platz bei letztern Wahl
und es wird sehr spannend zu sehen ob
wir genau das gleiche erleben wie 2017
und ob er womöglich über 30% sein wird
also wir werden die ersten Reaktionen
hier sofort ihn mitteilen also wie sieht
es mit marien lopen aus Valerie
sehr starken Wahlkampf geführt wie ist
da die Stimmung in ihrem Hauptquartier
haben sie mich verstanden
die Anhänger haben schon die masseiers
gesungen und rufen marienpräsident
marien also marienpräsidentin also die
sind hier sehr ungeduldig und auch etwas
beunruhigt natürlich
wir haben sechs Gäste im Studio
nicht ergreifen
[Musik]
ja wir haben noch eine Minute 30 dann
bekommen wir die ersten Hochrechnungen
und Laurent bei unserem umfrage-institut
wie geht es ihnen
Zahlen haben die ersten Reaktionen
kommen wir gleich hier wir haben dann
das Zusammentreffen der Kandidat mit
ihren Anhängern oder herrscht große
Ungeduld es gibt die ersten Andeutungen
die ersten Indizien dafür wie es
ausgehen könnte wir werden also der
Countdown läuft und
bevor wir die ersten Hochrechnungen um
20 Uhr offenbaren geht's weiter
wir so haben wir vor fünf Jahren marien
Lippen und macron Müller Jean hat ja
einen spektakulärer Aufholjagd hin
gelegt bald werden wir es wissen
Erektion
wird er vielleicht Überraschung
und was wird aus Valerie pecress
hat und wie ist es bei den Ökologen also
dieser erste Wahlgang der
präsidentwahlen läuft heute Abend und
die Franzosen haben ihre Wahl getroffen
und jetzt haben wir gleich in sieben
Sekunden die ersten Hinweise auf wer ist
scheidender Präsident also am 4
Präsident wer ist Herausforder 28,1
Prozent für immer grauen nach den ersten
Hochrechnung gegenüber Valerie Marie
Lübben mit
23,3%. also dieselbe Ausgangsbasis wie
2017 auch da im ersten Wahlgang sah so
aus und da ist ein großer freudentaume
jean-chow mit 20,1%
auf den dritten Platz mit 20,1 Prozent
das ist mehr als besser als 2017 7,2%
Erik Semur
mit fünf Prozent
dann die ökologische Partei mit Jannik
ja Dom mehr als 4% jonal 3,3%
2,7 Prozent Nikola Division 2,3 Prozent
und an idalgo von der sozialistischen
Partei PS mit 2,1%. jetzt kommen die
zwei extrem linken Natalie achso mit
0,8% in Kultur mit 0,7 Prozent also wir
werden bald hören was die beiden
spinnenkandidaten die vorne liegen zu
sagen haben es sieht nach einem neuen
Duell aus zwischen Emmanuel macron und
marienloipen wie sieht's denn aus bei
ihnen da im Hauptquartier von macron
also hier wie Sie sich vorstellen können
hier ein
Explosion der Freude als fronteur hier
die Resultate die erst Hochrechnung
bekannt gegeben hat also einige hundert
Anhänger von immer noch haben hier
sozusagen den Countdown runtergezählt
und die Atmosphäre ist hier wirklich
heiß der gegen 21 Uhr wird der Kandidat
sprechen
28,1% für immer nur macron der also
vorne liegt im ersten Wahlgang und er
liegt vor Marine Le Pen also er hat den
ersten Schritt geschafft die erste
Herausforderung über Boden Valerie ruhig
jetzt ist Marine Le Pen im zweiten
Wahlgang wohl wieder dabei mit 23,3%
ja ich verstehe sie hier sehr schlecht
weil sie hören ja hinter mir eine große
Erleichterung ein großer Lärm also schon
wieder wurde die Masse jetzt gesungen
und die Zeit ist kurz stehen geblieben
beim Countdown und alle haben gespannt
zugehört und dann große Erleichterung
hier im Lager von Marie Le Pen das ihre
Kandidatin ist in der zweiten Wahlgang
geschafft hat
vielen Dank Valerie wir machen weiter
mit den anderen Anhänger der anderen
Kandidaten
also nochmal 28,1% für immer macron
23,3% für marinepend dahinter zwar 20,1
Prozent melanchance und Erik Semo
dahinter als Vierter mit 7,1% und all
das wird hier noch analysiert Jean-Luc
mir noch schon 20,1 also der der Führer
der Linken im Moment wie wird die Linke
sich dann neu zusammensetzen 7,2 % für
Erik Semur auch das ist ein wichtiger
Punkt in dem Blick auf die zweiten
Wahlgang was wird in den nächsten
Stunden passieren jede Erklärung heute
Abend wird wichtig die ersten
politischen Erklärungen werden wir hier
auch mit Ann-Sophie erleben ja
unsere Gäste das Wort bekommen
möchten wir gerne die Ergebnisse
analysieren natürlich entsteht ja eine
neue politische Landschaft mit einem
weiteren Erfolg für immer macron sein
Ergebnis zeigt dass er vorne liegt und
er hat gegenüber 2017 sein Ergebnis
sogar noch verbessert und es ist auch
ein Erfolg für Marine auch sie hat ihr
Ergebnis verbessert und das trotz der
Konkurrenz von Erik Simu die große
Enttäuschung für Jeanette Milan Chance
der sein Ergebnis von 2017 verbessert
hat aber die Qualifikation für den
zweiten Wahlgang verpasster 2,7 % für
semuros RAM der ist ein es gibt
natürlich den kolossalen Zusammenbruch
der sozialistischen Partei und der alten
republikanischen Partei das ist wirklich
ein Umwälzung der politischen Landschaft
die Wähler haben in den letzten Tagen
wirklich für die drei genannten
Spitzenkandidaten gestimmt
Regress und sie der stimmt von PCs haben
sich verteilt auf macron und die andere
und Le Pen also wirklich eine neue
politische Landschaft eine neue drei
Parteienlandschaft und eine
Radikalisierung auf der linken also
sie sehen hier die Bilder aus dem
Hauptquartier von macron das ist ein
Sieg auch für jean-below vielleicht
nicht der Sieg auf den er gehofft hat
aber es ist ein Sieg er hat über 20
Prozent
20,1 das ist in einem ersten Opium sein
Ergebnis Serge Semino das ist das der
Sieg einer starken ganz starken
Wahlkampf ein Führer der Linken aber
nicht im zweiten Wahlgang
der dritte Platz nützt nichts
aber
Ergebnis von ist trotzdem sehr viel
besser als 2017
der Linken das wird sich zeigen also
wir werden sehen wie das nach den
nächsten Parlamentswahlen aussehen wird
aber die gesamte Linke hatte Jean Luc
millow vorgeworfen nur an seiner
Ergebnis zu denken und die Linke zu
spalten aber Jeanette Melone hat es
nicht geschafft
den den zweiten Wahlgang zu bekommen was
eigentlich sein Ziel war also naja gut
wir werden jetzt mal weiter sehen welche
Ergebnisse ihr noch kommen wir sehen auf
dem Bildschirm die Entwicklung der
Gesundheit noch jemand am vierter Stelle
erregt Semur
7,2%, also es unter 10% geblieben also
was wird er denn jetzt machen nachdem
zersplitterungen auf der extremen
Rechten was wie wird das auch
weitergehen wir haben hier eine
Anhängerin von Erik Semur
als die ersten Prognosen verkündet
wurden sehr viel Pfeifen hier gegeben
sehr viel Buhn als das Gesicht von
macron erschienen ist aber direkt danach
gab es Beifall denn die Anhänger und
Anhängerinnen wollten natürlich ihrem
Kandidaten auch Applaus geben sie haben
bei der Kampagne direkt mitgemacht was
sagen sie wir sind natürlich enttäuscht
klar wir haben mit einem viel besseren
Ergebnis gerechnet was anderes kann ich
jetzt nicht sagen aber es ist noch der
Anfang eines Abenteuers und machen sie
weiter natürlich macht auch Ericsson nur
weiter er wird nicht aufgeben für mich
ist das das erste Mal dass ich überhaupt
in der Politik aktiv geworden bin ich
habe vor Ort gearbeitet
auch heute morgen noch habe ich Fahrten
übernommen und ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dass
mehr Leute das Programm hätten hätten
sie sich auch begeistern können für ihn
und für das was er für Frankreich will
für wen werden sie denn in zwei Wochen
stimmen
sicherlich nicht für Emmanuel macron nun
ich glaube ich muss diese Neuigkeit
erstmal verdauen ich möchte gleich Eriks
Nummer zuhören und ich glaube dass wir
haben alles so viel investiert
da ging es nicht um rechts und links es
geht um seine Persönlichkeit um seine
Philosophie und die hat uns alle
mitgerissen und er wird weitermachen und
wir auch vielen Dank
jetzt zu den Gästen
Prozent der Stimmen bekommen sie hat
schon gesagt dass ihre Anhänger für
Emanuel macron in zwei Wochen Stimmen
sollen und die drei ersten haben ja mehr
als 20 Prozent also es bleibt gar nicht
mehr so viel für die anderen übrig
sie vertreten Emmanuel macron hier diese
28,1% könnt ihr es mal durchschnaufen ja
auf jeden Fall das ist ein klasse
Ergebnis nach fünf Jahren an der
Regierung in denen er sich bewähren
konnte aber es bleibt noch viel alles
vor uns zu tun ich möchte allen danken
die für uns gewählt haben die für uns
gestimmt haben und
bitte jetzt um eine starke Mobilisierung
für den zweiten Wahlgang jetzt fängt der
zweite Wahlkampf an also ich appelliere
an alle sich da in die Wäsche zu werfen
in den Kampf zu werfen
wir müssen natürlich auch nachdenken wie
wir jetzt damit umgehen es wird eine
wirklich leidenschaftlich und kämpfter
zweiter Wahlgang werden
da es stehen zwei Visionen der
französischen Nation gegeneinander
einmal die Vision
des Wohlstandes der Fähigkeit die
Vollbeschäftigung herzustellen
Frankreich zu einem attraktiven Land zu
machen ein Land das sich für die Umwelt
und den gegen den Klimawandel engagiert
auch bereit ist im Kampf gegen den
Klimawandel vorne zu sein und ein
Frankreich das eine wichtige Rolle in
der europäischen Diskussion gespielt hat
sind mit einer europäischen Vision das
Verteidigung das ist unser Frankie das
wir wollen und wir wollen dass die
Menschen sich für diese Vision
mobilisieren lassen um dann im zweiten
Wagen für macron zu stimmen
hat 23,3% der Stimmen bekommen mehr als
2017 aber der auf der Abstand ist größer
geworden zu macron ist es dennoch ein
Sieg
tolle Leistung mit einer Süßigkeiten
ich denke jetzt gibt es warum in einem
zweiten Wahlgang die Stimmen zu sammeln
jetzt wird die Diskussion stattfinden
und das über sehr wichtige Themen es
geht um Kaufkraft um die Ergebnisse der
Politik von Mission macron und das finde
ich dass der zweite Wahlgang noch ganz
ein ganz offenes Rennen ist also es gibt
viele Kandidaten die nicht Monsieur
macron im zweiten einen in aller zweiten
Amtszeit sehen wollen und jetzt geht es
darum diese stimmen alle hinter Marie
lopen zusammen
sie stehen für Jeanette er hat auch mehr
Stimmen bekommen bleibt aber auf dem
dritten Platz nun ist das wird er kaum
schön finden
was sagen sie dazu
und Männer die sehr viel Hoffnung
gesetzt haben in ihre Wahlzettel wir
hatten eine Mobilisierung insbesondere
der Jugend aus den Vierteln der
einfachen Leute die sehr viel Hoffnung
dargesetzt haben für mir doch schon zu
stimmen die haben sehr große Probleme im
Alltag und ich möchte Ihnen sagen all
die für uns gestimmt haben da möchte ich
sagen was auch wenn dieses Ergebnis uns
vom zweiten Übergang ausschließt
bedeutet 20,1 Prozent das ist Stimmen
gibt für den Respekt vor den einfachen
Menschen und wir werden weiter diesen
Kampf führen und ja soweit die
Berichterstattung von France död zu den
Kollegen werden wir später noch mal
zurückkommen und ich begrüße jetzt
abermals meinen Kollegen Michael krons
in Paris er ist ich hatte es vorhin
schon mal gesagt den redaktionsräum das
Fernsehsenders France von catre ein
privaten informationssender Michael wie
ist denn diese erste Hochrechnung in den
in der Redaktion aufgenommen worden
ja mit Überraschung wir hatten ja ganz
andere Zahlen vorher gehört in den
Umfragen und insofern ist der Abstand
doch sehr viel größer als wir angenommen
hatten und das ist zumindest was auch
melanchance anbetrifft natürlich auch
sehr spannend zu sehen wie sich das in
Richtung zweitem Wahlgang entwickelt bei
mir ist der Chef Kommentator von was war
katre und Herren binski auch sie waren
erstmal überrascht über diese Zahlen
natürlich weil man also wenn man
erwartet hatte dass die Rechtsextremen
die im ultra Rechte mit Marine Lippen
und besser abschneiden würden und das
ist nicht der Fall wahrscheinlich liegt
das an der geringen Wahlbeteiligung das
muss man natürlich alles nachdenken und
nachschauen im Verlauf dieses Abends
aber irgendwie ist es schon ein eine
Überraschung würde ich sagen
zweifellos eine schöne Überraschung weil
wir hier bei 500
humanistisch engagiert sind und da
können wir nicht einfach so mitsehen wie
Leute wie Simone eventuell die macht ja
greifen könnten das ist ja eine Sache
aber die zweite Sache ist das
wahrscheinlich auch die Leute die sich
die haben sich als was man früher
republikanische Front genannt hatte das
heißt wie die demokratischen Kräfte sich
zusammen bald zusammen tun um der
extremen Rechte eine Sperre zu Macht zu
machen und das ist vielleicht weil die
der Grund weshalb diese diese Welle
schon beim ersten Wahlgang diese
Entscheidung getroffen haben mal sehen
beim zweiten Wahlgang ob sich das
bestellt habe ich nämlich sofort eine
Frage zu Jeanette melanchow der linke
der ja auch mit Thesen wie wir gehen
raus aus der NATO sehr viel Unruhe
verbreitet unter den anderen EU-Ländern
der hat immerhin 20% bekommen das ist
auch Überraschung ja ich denke also für
linke Leute ist zurück und seine
Kandidatur als Sammelbecken für
frustriertheit für Verdrossenheit und
die spielt eigentlich als
Becken für für für
soziale Ungerechtigkeit und die dagegen
kämpfen und das ist natürlich also das
ist ein Erbe
Sozialistischen Partei die sich aber
distanziert und Abstand davon genommen
hat und er ist wahrscheinlich im Stande
zu
ergattern also zu die diese Welle zu
ergattern die sich gegen Rechts gegen
die Rechte einsetzen und die trotzdem
einen Hauch an Populismus anhaben
Ende haben und und für uns schätzen und
diese dieses Ergebnis in Frankreich
führte nicht nur auf die soziale
ökonomischen Verhältnisse auch auf diese
kulturelle dieses kulturellen Gefühl der
abhängig abhängig sein diese abhängig
sein als eins und das hat eine sehr
große Rolle gespielt wahrscheinlich aber
wenn wir sagen Eric und auch Maria Le
Pen aber auch die Linken nämlich
melanchance sind eigentlich die
Populisten die mit einfachen Thesen wir
senken die Steuern wir kriegen das alles
hin wir gehen aus der NATO raus aus der
EU raus einen Erfolg erzielt haben aber
keinen ganz so großen ist ja jetzt die
entscheidende Frage für die Stichwahl
wie sieht es denn eigentlich aus mit den
melonchance Stimmen wo gehen die denn da
hin
das ist ja die Frage denn es ist sogar
die Gretchenfrage
man geht davon aus dass die meisten
Welle von solique Milow Show
entweder sich enthalten werden oder
jeder also doch für macron stimmen
würden aber das ist ja sehr sehr
unsicher ist jetzt und zu 20 25 Prozent
Dorf für immer den lebend stimmen würden
und das ist ja auch eine Überraschung
ideologische Überraschung so haben sie
das Populismus genannt das ist auch
wahrscheinlich die die die Weichen
Stellung wo man einsieht das linke Leute
eventuell möglicherweise für recht für
ultra-rechtliche stehen können haben Sie
den Eindruck wir reden jetzt über
bestimmte programmatische Absichten da
kann man sagen bei Marine Le Pen die
will ich Steuern senken die will denen
denjenigen die sie in den Dörfern
besucht haben mehr Kaufkraft geben das
ist ja so eine Thematik gewesen aber sie
will eine ganze Menge auch in Europa
ändern die Franzosen sollen über größere
Vorhaben in der Europäischen Union
entscheiden jedes Mal entscheiden das
ist schon ein Abstand den man zu Europa
dann haben will aus ihrer nicht das ist
nicht mehr das Europa was wir vor allen
Dingen aus Deutschland und Frankreich
als enges Band dann sehen würden das auf
jeden Fall
die meisten Franzosen auch die die nicht
unbedingt rechts engagiert sind oder
rechts ein bestimmt sind haben kein
keine feste Ahnung oder keine feste
Vorstellung
das heißt keine exakte Vorstellung von
dem was Europa ist empfunden
von dem es günstig ist und wie es wert
sein kann Europa und die hatten immer
den Eindruck dass die Grande Nation
irgendwie groß sind dazu hier in
Frankreich sich selbst entwickeln kann
dass alle Möglichkeiten offen sind und
dass sie keine milchshilfe oder keine
Kooperation brauchen und das führt auch
dazu zurück zu dazu zurück dass Leute
wie Simone so gut abgeschnitten sind
oder regelmäßig so gut abschneiden weil
Vorstellung
des Übermut zu Frankreichs das ist was
wahrscheinlich sehr wichtig ist in der
Europäischen Union in den Ländern ist
jetzt überall das Gefühl ausgebrochen
wir müssen zusammenstehen die
Solidarität ist bei den EU-Gipfeln beim
Nato-Gipfel immer wieder beschworen
worden in Deutschland ist das ein sehr
kräftiger Begriff und eine kräftige
Unterstützung geworden ist Frankreich
noch nicht so im Fokus oder nimmt
Frankreich den Ukraine Krieg noch nicht
so in den Fokus bei den Themen bei der
Wahl war die UK eine relativ weit unten
denken das sagen es ist schon eindeutig
aber was die was die Ukraine angeht zum
Beispiel haben die Leute erst mal
gedacht das ist ja fürchterlich und das
ging das für meine auf die zugunsten von
Immanuel macron und das war eigentlich
nicht der Fall weil die meisten
Prognosen für ihn abgesunken sind
inzwischen mittlerweile und das hat
nichts viel geändert an dem an dem an
dem Rad an dem kotus von Marie Lippen
z.B im Ergebnis von marien Lippen das
heißt wir haben hier in Frankreich die
wahrscheinlich in allen Ländern also
europäischen Länder sehr emotional
reagiert aber politisch gedacht und
nachgedacht nicht und die meisten
Französinnen zum Beispiel Ben Wähler die
denken
das ist ja sehr weit von Ukraine obwohl
2000 km von hier entfernt dass ich ja
sehr weit und wir sollten uns nicht
kümmern drum drum kümmern das Putin hat
vielleicht sein Recht sein gutes Recht
und das ist nicht unsere Sache
rabinski ganz herzlichen Dank das war
der Chef kommandator von France war
katre hier direkt aus Paris und wir
geben direkt zurück nach Bonn
ja herzlichen Dank Herr Michael krons
aus Paris und wir sind jetzt wieder
verbunden mit Ronja Kempin sie ist von
der Stiftung Politik und Wissenschaft in
Berlin Frau Kempin die ersten Zahlen die
wir gesehen haben haben sie die
überrascht
also ein Stück weit hatte auch ich
tatsächlich
leben und macron näher beieinander
gesehen ich bin wieder französische
Kollege auch zunächst erstmal beruhigt
dass wir doch einen deutlichen Abstand
zwischen beiden
wahrnehmen können das ist die beiden in
die Stichwahl am 24 April schaffen das
ist uns ja in den letzten fünf sechs
Wochen doch immer wieder sozusagen als
es wahrscheinlichst des Szenario durch
ganz unterschiedliche Umfragen immer
wieder bestätigt worden aber ich will
vielleicht sagen ein Ergebnis hat mich
tatsächlich dann doch beunruhigt und das
ist wenn wir die Stimmen zusammenzählen
die Marine Le Pen Erik semour und jean-
Milos auf sich vereinen konnten dann
sind das 50% der abgegebenen Stimmen des
heutigen Abends also 50% der
Wahlberechtigten in Frankreich haben für
extreme Politikerinnen und Politiker
gestimmt und das ist schon etwas was uns
doch sehr beunruhigen sollte die
traditionellen Parteien die Sozialisten
und die Republikaner die das Land dem
Land über 60 Jahre Stabilität verliehen
haben sind mit dem heutigen Tag wirklich
in der Bedeutungslosigkeit eigentlich
verschwunden ja in der
Bedeutungslosigkeit an idalgo die
Bürgermeisterin von Paris die für die
Sozialisten angetreten ist da zum
Beispiel nur 2,1 Prozent also die
ehemaligen Volksparteien wirklich in der
Bedeutungslosigkeit wie sie es gesagt
haben wenn wir uns jetzt Zahlen des
ersten Wahlgangs von 2017 anschauen da
hat man sehr viel knapper vor
Marienleben letztendlich gelegen da war
er bei 24 und sie bei
21,3
als wir dann zu dem zweiten Wahlgang
ging war das Ergebnis dann sehr sehr
deutlich da hat macron mit 66,1 Prozent
gewonnen und Marie le Pen hatte 33 moin
würden Sie sagen das ist wieder zu
erwarten
das ist zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
tatsächlich ganz schwer also natürlich
kennen wir Umfragen die Voraussagen dass
die der Ausgang der Stichwahl in zwei
Wochen sehr viel enger ausfallen wird
als noch vor fünf Jahren also es gibt
Umfragen die sagen 53 Prozent für macron
plus minus
spiegelbildlich dann eben 47 Prozent
plus minus für Marine Le Pen wir sehen
dass die
rechtsextreme Kandidatin also Marine Le
Pen
vermutlich an größeres Villa Reservoir
hat
sie kann auf einen Teil sicherlich der
Stimmen von Erik Semur zählen sie kann
möglicherweise auch auf anderen Teil der
Stimmen von zählen
und bei macron ist es so ein bisschen
offen ob er jetzt die anderen Stimmen
der schlecht platzierten wenn Sie so
wollen pikresse i dalgo der das
kann ich gleich helfen noch mal
einwerfen Frau Kempin das percrets
Valerie per Cres gerade dazu aufgerufen
hat macron tatsächlich zu wählen also
sie ist eine von denen die tatsächlich
ihre Wähler nun in das Lager von macron
führen will aber die ganz spannende
Frage ist ja sie haben gesagt 50%
Extremisten das ist natürlich ein
riesiges Potenzial dass die Stimmen von
Le Pen zusammen mit dem Mur
wahrscheinlich zusammenkommen das kann
man sich gut vorstellen aber dass die
Stimmen von melanchance tatsächlich in
das Lager von Le Pen überwandern besteht
da wirklich eine eine Möglichkeit
also es ich könnte mir vorstellen dass
ich die Stimmen von Milos möglicherweise
zu einem großen Teil oder dass
diejenigen die heute für Jeanette
melonchance gestimmt haben zu einem
großen Teil im in der Stichwahl am 24
April nicht zur Wahl mehr gehen werden
bei ihnen ist Emmanuel macron wirklich
ganz ganz unbeliebt gerade zu verhasst
denn macron hat die Linke ein Stück weit
verraten die Linke fühlt sich zumindest
von ihm ein Stück weit
verraten er ist in seinen politischen
Positionen ganz weit nach rechts
abgerückt und hat die politische Linke
eigentlich ohne Führung zurück gelassen
ohne Versprechen auch und deshalb kann
ich mir schwer vorstellen dass sich
viele aus dem millochon-lager sozusagen
in Richtung macron aufmachen es gibt
aber interessan teilweise eben in vielen
Positionen gerade mit Blick auf die
Europäische Union mit Blick auf die NATO
die internationale Politik
die sozialen Fragen eine große
Übereinstimmung mit Positionen
von
Marine Le Pen und wir können davon
ausgehen dass vielleicht ein Fünftel der
Wählerinnen und Wähler die am heutigen
Abend für Jean bin noch schon gestimmt
haben in zwei Wochen ihre Stimme für
Marille Pen abgeben sie haben es gerade
gesagt das ist ja schon erstaunlich dass
da zwei Extremisten aus völlig
unterschiedlichen Lagern dann so groß
und Schnittmengen haben lebend hat ja im
Wahlkampf sehr auch auf die kleinen
Leute gesetzt hat ihn mehr Geld
versprochene Monat müssten das
mindestens 200 Euro mehr sein und diese
Dinge das sind die eigentlich ganz linke
Parolen wie passt das denn eigentlich
zusammen in das rechtsradikalere Lage
ja ich glaube Marille Penner hat schon
seit Jahren eigentlich versucht soziale
Themen für sich und ihre Partei zu
erschließen sie hat schon das Thema
Kaufkraft sehr früh im Prinzip für für
sich erkannt sie hat nie mit den
gelbwesten offen sympathisiert aber sie
hat zum Beispiel eine gelbe Weste dann
hinten in ihrem Auto gehabt als die GAP
Westen Proteste
fahrtaufnahmen im Land also sie hat
schon immer dieses
ja dieses soziale
Antlitz ihrer Partei verpasst und ich
glaube das zahlt sich jetzt eben aus
insbesondere in einem Moment in dem
Präsident macron die soziale Schraube
wieder etwas stärker andrehen will
ja erstmal vielen Dank Frau Kempin wir
schalten uns noch mal auf zu den
Kollegen von françao und schauen die
weitere der weiteren Berichterstattung
dazu
der Kandidat der Grünen hat gerade zur
Wahl von Immanuel macron im zweiten
Wahlgang aufgerufen
unsere Stimme
die
gilt nicht als Freifahrtschein für
macron weiterzumachen mit der
Zersplitterung des Landes und mit der
Verachtung für demokratische Vorgänge
und Prozesse
[Applaus]
es gilt auch nicht als Unterstützung für
das Projekt das immer wenn das
Wahlkampfes skizziert hat das obliegt
jetzt dem Kandidaten im modernen macron
dafür zu sorgen dass sich die Mehrheit
der Franzosen hinter ihm sammeln kann um
der extremen Rechten einen Niederlage
beizufüllen der Kampf für das Klima geht
weiter für unser Überleben als Menschen
und für dieses Land was Wunden davon
getragen hat und dass wir lieben ich
danke ihnen es lebe der Umweltschutz es
lebe die Republik es lebe Frankreich
[Applaus]
Stand zu sein mit ihrem Kandidat
wir haben ja gerade Jannik
er hat dafür gesorgt dass die extreme
Rechte an Bedeutung zugenommen hat und
jetzt liegt der Ball bei ihm er muss
jetzt dafür sorgen
diejenigen für ihn stimmen die aber
eigentlich
ignoriert hat
die gelbwesten die Arbeitslosen die
Grünen
er braucht sie jetzt und das ist das
Szenario dass er gewünscht hat und für
das er verantwortlich ist aber das ist
unwürdig und sind
die alle starkzügel weltbehälter ich
wähle macron um Marine zu verändern aber
wenn er jetzt vor mir stünde würde ich
sagen sie müssen runter von ihrem Sockel
sie haben die Französin und Französin
nicht gehört sie haben
sich mächtig dargestellt aber jetzt sind
Sie dran sie müssen jetzt alle einzeln
abholen denn ansonsten werden sie ihrer
historischen Wartung nicht gerecht ja
ein Moment
wir sind jetzt im Hauptquartier von
anidalgo und wir hören ihren ersten
Beitrag gleich
man hört hier noch einmal die Stimme von
jadeaux der dazu aufruft zu Emmanuel
macron zu stimmen aber
hören wir jetzt an die dalgo nein hallo
sie waren da gerade mit einem
sozialistischen Senator der Nordregion
aber sie natürlich sehr enttäuscht von
diesem Ergebnis die Sozialistische
Partei ist mal wieder nicht beim zweiten
Wahlgang dabei und sie liegen sogar noch
unter 5%, das ist ein ein politisches
Erdbeben
ja Herr Senator hätten sie sich das
vorstellen können dass sie noch
schlechter abschneiden als 2017 Daten
sehr
6,29% jetzt sind sie nur bei 2%, das ist
wirklich ein Erdbeben das ist eine
riesige politische Enttäuschung aber ich
halte fest dass wir zum zweiten Mal die
Linke aus dem zweiten Wahlgang
ausgeschlossen ist dieses Ergebnis
zwingt uns alle darüber nachzudenken was
mit der sogenannten nützlichen
Stimmabgabe ist dass man aus taktischen
Erwägungen für immer noch Chance
gestimmt hat um Leben zu verhindern also
ich dieses Beruf jetzt dringend dazu auf
sich darüber nach sich darüber Gedanken
zu machen die Linke muss Lösungen bieten
und die in der Republik präsentieren
also dieses ein sehr kompliziertes
Ergebnis für uns aber wir haben sehr
viele Abgeordnete auf kommunaler und
regionaler Ebene wir haben da immer noch
was zu sagen in der Politik und ich rufe
dazu auf sich vor allem für die
Parlamentswahlen zusammenzufinden und
jetzt rufe ich erstmal auf im zweiten
Wahlgang macron zu wählen weil die
extreme Rechte nicht die Lösung ist und
die Sozialistische Partei ist nicht tot
wir haben so viele Abgeordneten in den
Regionen und in den Gemeinden wir werden
vom von der politischen Landschaft aus
von der Breite aus uns wieder aufbauen
die Franzosen haben Lösungen den Rücken
gekehrt die ihn seit Jahren darum
gepriesen werden und wir müssen jetzt
diagnostizieren was los ist und Lösungen
vorschlagen ich rufe die Linke dazu auf
sich zu mobilisieren erstmal für den
zweiten Wahlgang da die extrem rechte zu
verhindern aber dann Nachkommen die
Parlamentswahlen und da werden die
Karten neu gemischt
vielen
Danko zu sagen hat die Kandidatin die
gesprochen hat vor ihren Anhängern
also wir werden dann anidalgo etwas
später hören also marien Le Pen die an
zweiter Position steht sie hat sich
damit für zum zweiten Mal für den
zweiten Wahlgang qualifiziert und jetzt
spricht sie vor ihren Anhängern 23,6%
marienloipen spricht jetzt zu ihren
Anhängern
meine lieben Landsleute die Franzosen im
Kernland die Franzosen Übersee die
Franzosen weltweit das französische Volk
hat gewählt und hat mir die Ehre
erwiesen dass ich für den zweiten
Wahlsonntag in der Stichwahl bin
an die Millionen der Wähler und
WählerInnen sage ich heute aufrichtigen
Dank ich
nehme die Verantwortung mit Demut an und
ich habe die Hoffnung dass wir dieses
Land wieder nach vorne bringen heute
haben die Franzosen eine Wahl getroffen
zwischen zwei entgegensetzlichen
Versionen der Zukunft entweder
Ungerechtigkeit Unordnung und Bruch
verkörpert durch Herrn macron aber
schutzgerechtigkeit war die andere
Version Brüderlichkeit und eine Vision
von Einheit und Volk diejenigen die
heute nicht für macron bestimmt haben
wollen sicherlich zu unserem Blog dazu
gehören
[Applaus]
ich freue mich
dass
dieser Wahlkampf loyal sein wird und in
den nächsten 14 Tagen soll das
französische Volk in eine Möglichkeit
bekommen einen fundierte Wahl in zwei
Wochen zu treffen
wir brauchen keine Klientelpolitik wir
stehen im Dienst von allen und ich wende
mich direkt an Sie
wenn Sie das so wollen werde ich ab dem
nächsten Tag nach dem zweiten
Wahlsonntag die Präsidentin aller
Franzosen sein
und am 24 April geht es nicht um eine
zufällige Wahl es geht um eine
Entscheidung für die Kultur und ein Land
ihre Stimme
bestimmt dass die französische Kultur
und die Sprache hier letztendlich
Vorrang haben unsere Werte der Republik
und die Laizität und die Gleichheit
zwischen Mann und Frau die Wellen sie
mit einer Stimme für mich mit ihrer
Stimme gestalten sie auch die
Gesellschaft
und die Stellung des Geldes
Solidarität gegenüber den verletzlichen
über den schwachen es geht
darum dass man gesund in die Rente
eintreten kann am 24 April
eine Weichenstellung für die nächsten
fünf Jahre wie steht Frankreich in den
nächsten fünf Jahren da Sicherheit
Einwanderung soziale Energie Europa
Militär deplomatie diese Themen sind mir
wichtig und ich sorge für die nationale
Einheit
es geht darum dass Franzosen ihre
Interessen frei entscheiden und
gestalten können und ich werde die
Sicherheit für alle wiederherstellen
denn ich höre zu und ich achte darauf
dass
Ihre Interessen gewahrt werden vor allem
die von den einfachen Menschen von den
öffentlichen Angestellten sie sind sehr
oft ignoriert worden in den letzten fünf
Jahren und
ich werde nüchtern alle analysieren was
zu tun ist und ich werde ihn dann ein
Konzept vorstellen mit Zahlen und ich
gehe mit Ernsthaftigkeit dran ich sehe
dass es sehr viele Brüche gibt in der
französischen Gesellschaft
soziale Brüche kulturellen in der im
digitalen in den Krankenhäusern ich
sorge in den nächsten fünf Jahren für
Ordnung frankreich muss im 21
Jahrhundert den Platz bekommen den es
verdient voller Chancen voller Würde und
es geht um sehr viele ehrgeizige Ziele
Demokratie mit einem Bürgerentscheid das
möchte ich umsetzen mit einer
Verhältniswahlrecht bei den Wahlen das
auch alle gehört werden und auch in der
National vertreten sind
auch ökologische und ökonomisch habe ich
ehrgeizige Ziele
[Applaus]
economic ecologic wirtschaftliche und
ökologische Ziele Rückkehr zur
Vollbeschäftigung Rückkehr zum Wohlstand
ökonomischer patriotismus ist ganz
wichtig und wir müssen die kleinst und
mittelständischen Unternehmen Stützen
Wert muss wieder einen Wert haben und
Beteiligung im Kapital soziale Ziele wir
brauchen wieder eine Schule wo
gelernt wird und wir brauchen ein
Gesundheitssystem das erschwinglich ist
und natürlich auch Wohnraum zu einem
erschwinglichen Preis wir wollen keinen
zurücklassen
eine glückliche Familie haben können
persönlich sich entfalten können egal
welcher Herkunft er ist und der Staat
muss fürsorglich sein und auch für seine
Beamten sorgen ein Staat der allen
Freiheit garantiert ein Staat am
richtigen Platz der sich im Dienste
seiner Bürger sieht und ich möchte die
Franzosen um dieses große Projekt
Verbindungen zwischen den Generationen
müssen gestärkt werden wir sind eine
Schicksalsgemeinschaft wir sind
unbesiegbar und Frankreich ist ein Land
das wieder ein wohlstandsland wird ich
möchte
alle Franzosen egal welcher politischen
Strömung und Überzeugung egal wo Sie
sind bitte machen Sie mit bei diesem
großen Projekt gemeinsam werden wir mit
Begeisterung und Überzeugung diesen Sieg
bekommen es geht um den großen Wechsel
den Frankreich braucht und dann werden
wir heiter in das nächste Jahrtausend
schreiten
so weit marien Lübben heute am 23,6% an
zweiter Stelle somit für den zweiten
Wahlgang qualifiziert und Jean Malone
der
dieser Stelle gelandet ist
wird gleich zu seinen Anhängern sprechen
Twitter erklärt keine Zweifel daran
lassen keine Zweideutigkeiten keine
Stimme für die extreme Rechte also
sie wollten glaube ich Ihren Beitrag
noch beenden warum hat ihre Kandidatin
so eine Niederlage hingelegt sieht
einfach
wir sind eine politische Familie und
jetzt geht es um die zukunftskrankheit
des Schicksal von Frankreich darum geht
es heute Abend klar meine erste
Feststellung ist Marine Le Pen hat mehr
Stimmen bekommen Emmanuel macron hat
aber sein Versprechen nicht halten
können denn er hat gesagt ich werde die
extreme vermeiden
und sieben da haben wir es geschafft
hier extreme im Schach zu halten
ja soweit die Kollegen von François und
wir sind noch mal verbunden mit Ronja
Kempin von der Stiftung Wissenschaft und
Politik in Berlin Frau Kempin ein
Ergebnis das vor allem deshalb erstaunt
weil die radikalen Kräfte so stark sind
und es noch mal kurz zu zeigen es wird
hier eine Stichwahl geben macron hat
28,1 Prozent und Marine Le Pen
23,3%. die Frage ist nun was muss man
vor Ort stellen um wiedergewählt zu
werden
ja ich glaube in erster Linie muss er
zwei Dinge machen er muss sichtbar
werden das haben wir ihm ja vorgeworfen
dass er das eigene Land im Wahlkampf
vernachlässigt hat der hat sich sehr
viel auf die internationale Bühne
sozusagen kapriziert und der hat sehr
wenig dafür getan das Vertrauen in eine
zweite Amtszeit unter den Französinnen
und Franzosen sozusagen wachsen zu
lassen das muss er jetzt schleunigst
nachholen und ich glaube er wird
Zugeständnisse machen müssen an die
politische Linke wir haben vorhin schon
über Jean-Luc Milos und die Stimmen die
er hinter sich vereinigen konnte
gesprochen wem werden die mir noch schon
Anhänger ihre Stimme in der Stichwahl in
zwei Wochen ergeben ich glaube ohne
Zugeständnisse an die politische Linke
das betrifft die Rentenreform das
betrifft eben die Ankündigung die
daumenschr gerade auch mit Blick auf die
Sozialhilfeempfänger EmpfängerInnen eben
anzuschrauben ich glaube da ist er
gefragt und er wird sich auch
ökologischen Themen noch mal wieder
stärker zuwenden müssen um eben diese
Stimmen
für sich ja bekommen zu können und um
den Abstand zu marien leben sozusagen so
groß wie möglich gestalten zu können und
natürlich wird der Marine auffordern
müssen
auszurechnen vorzurechnen wie sie ihre
soziale und ihre Wirtschaftspolitik
finanzieren will aber wir haben Marine
Le Pen gerade eben ja schon gehört in
ihrer Rede
sie hatte angesprochen dass im Dienste
aller Franzosen stehen will es ging um
die Kultur des Landes und Frankreich
würde bei ihr mal Vorrang haben aber sie
hat auch ökonomische Ziele genannt sie
sprach also auch von Vollbeschäftigung
das sind also auch die Themen die immer
cron durchaus auf seiner Liste hat
trifft sie da den richtigen Ton
ja wir haben es ja schon festgestellt
also Marine ist deutlich konzilianter
sie nimmt die Spitzen raus sie wirkt
weicher sie ist nicht mehr so aggressiv
im Ton und sie gibt sich wie die
Franzosen des nennen würden heute
präsidos also sie verleiht sich die
Statur einer Präsidentin die für das
ganze Volk sprechen will für das gesamte
Volk auch stehen will sie spricht davon
Frankreich zu vereinen das sind
tatsächlich Worte mit denen sie jetzt
schon den Weg sozusagen für die nächsten
zwei Wochen natürlich ebnet als
Schlussfrage dann gerne noch sehen wir
hier mit diesem Ergebnis was wir in
Frankreich jetzt gesehen haben ein
völlig zerrissenes Land das vielleicht
gerade noch mal den Blick auf sich
selber pflegt aber ansonsten mit sich
selbst vor allen Dingen beschäftigt ist
ja Frankreich ist schon lange mit sich
selbst beschäftigt es gab einen
wahnsinnig schnellen Strukturwandel den
eben viele Menschen nicht mitgemacht
haben
Globalisierungsgewinner und Verlierer
sind in Frankreich stark
ausdifferenziert dazu kam eben der
staatliche Rückbau wie wir es vorhin
auch angesprochen haben und zu all dem
dann eben immer wieder terroristische
Attacken die der Präsident auch nicht
hat verhindern lassen das hat das Land
tief verunsichert und in Teilen eben
auch gespalten und es ist in der Tat so
das Land die Bevölkerung sieht ihr Land
eigentlich in einem schlechteren Zustand
als es von außen betrachtet tatsächlich
da steht
vielen herzlichen Dank für ihre
Expertise hier bei uns in der Sendung
das war unser erster Teil über die
Wahlen in Frankreich es folgt nur die
Dokumentation der Frankreich wild und
schön und um 22 Uhr sind wir wieder mit
den neuesten Entwicklungen zur Wahl in
Frankreich wieder bei Ihnen
[Musik]